I'm unmuted on Lily's channel!
I like how chat has the biggest short-term memory.
I'm going to mute myself real quick to talk to Doki.
And the second I do that, they're like, Lily!
Lily, why can't you be muted?
You're muted!
I'm like, yeah, I just told you I was muted!
Wait, don't people say like, chat reflects the streamer?
No, that's so wrong.
No, that's not it at all!
Oh, that's wrong!
Are you trying to say they're dumber than you or they're smarter than you, though?
Whichever one gets me in less trouble.
Lily's chat, are you smarter or dumber than me?
She was wisely, chat!
She was wisely!
Wait, so what do I do?
I don't know about that one, chief.
Don't worry, my chat is a pure reflection of me.
Which is like, we're...
We're smart, we're great at FPS games, we're so funny.
We're so kind, we're generous, right, Dragoo?
Right, right?
Right, guys, right?
Yeah, I too am funny.
I didn't just spend like almost two hours talking about the game.
Oh yeah, I was listening.
No, wait, not that.
I thought you were talking about your cat!
I was listening to you talking about your fucking cat!
That's true, I have a cat throwing up, vomiting, all over my furniture, bro.
Bro!
Oh yeah, yeah, like, yeah, you were talking about your cat's allergies and you're like, oh, I'm gonna try and see what your cat's allergic to.
But like, yeah, you know like how like, pets can like suddenly develop allergies as they get older?
Which is fucked up.
It's so annoying!
What's it allergic to me?
Yeah, I was just like, how do you just suddenly become allergic?
Like, what's wrong with you?
Like, who purchased this DLC?
Stop, retry it, refund it.
What the fuck, man?
Evolution was not supposed to be like this.
I was taught that people evolve after hundreds and thousands of years.
Not five years!
Evolution isn't supposed to be this fast, stupid.
Go back.
How dare you!
How dare you evolve backwards!
Stop evolving backwards.
My pet is so fucked up, suddenly he's like allergic.
I'm like, stop, just stop evolving.
I'm like, I'm being allergic.
What the fuck?
Yeah, like, what the fuck?
Just stop evolving!
Stop it!
We domesticated you to not be like this!
Ryan, all these years of domestication, don't fuck it up.
Yeah, your ancestors are disappointed in you.
They're looking down at you being like, meow.
Wow, this is what I turned into?
You used to be a lion.
Lions are not allergic to farts.
You're a fucking kibble.
Like, what's wrong with you?
She's like, no, the kibble is too dry.
It upsets my tummy.
My tummy hurt now.
Your tummy hurt.
Your kibble got good.
We had to fight rhinos.
She's like, back in my day, we fought rhinos and now your tummy hurt?
What's wrong with you?
My tummy hurt.
Please, love my tummy.
Oh my god.
It's like when our parents go like, they tell stories about, when I used to go to school, I used to go through a snowstorm in a blizzard up a hill for 17 kilometers.
When I was your age, I was hunting rhinos.
Barefoot.
Slides.
Carrying my siblings.
I had to be an only child because we killed off the other children.
I ate the offspring.
And now you're gonna throw up in Lily's bed?
I can't hold my pee-pee.
I have to pee.
My kibble is too dry.
My kibble too dry.
Too dry.
Please, hydrate the kibble, please.
Please, rehydrate the kibble.
Please.
Yeah, my dog, he evolved into being allergic to chicken after eating chicken kibble.
Chicken?
Oh my god.
He grew up eating chicken kibble.
And then out of nowhere, he just started being allergic to chicken.
Oh my god.
It's like our dogs.
I don't know if it was turkey or duck.
It wasn't chicken, but it was like a different breed.
Turkey or duck.
Yeah.
We always give them like food left.
I was like, oh yeah, here, have a little treat, you know, on the side.
And suddenly, it's like...
He's acting really strange and I'm like, why?
Turns out suddenly he's allergic to duck.
Or turkey or whatever the fuck.
Oh my god.
I had to pay like...
Like lots and lots of money at this like specialist.
At this like allergy specialist.
To do like an allergy test on my dog.
And then I got the test back.
And he's literally allergic to like maple.
Like actual like maple trees and grass.
He's like allergic to certain types of grass.
And...
He's allergic to like...
Like certain types of bugs.
Like he's like, oh, you...
He shouldn't have any mosquito bites.
Because he's allergic to mosquitoes.
I was like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Imagine being this majestic wolf.
And then it's just like...
Oh, you know, grass hurty.
Grass hurty.
Outside.
Dangerous.
Like I don't wanna be outside.
I wanna be on couch.
I'm an inside dog now.
I want to be inside.
Every time I like take him out for a walk.
And I have to like wipe his paws.
Like get like those like wet wipes.
And wipe his paws.
When he can't see.
Oh, that's not like my paws.
It's time to wipe your paws.
Wow, you used to be a wolf.
Nice paw wipey time.
Come here little man.
Paw wipey, wipey.
Alright, before...
I just want you guys to know, chat.
Before we like started the stream.
When we were muted.
Lily was...
We were talking about the subcategories of furries.
It was a very interesting conversation.
It was, it was.
Oh my gosh, you guys should have seen.
Lily knew so much about like furry culture.
It was like, what were the subcategories of furries again, Lily?
What were they?
I don't...
Remind me again.
I don't remember.
I think you had some input on that one if I remember correctly.
You were like, okay.
So like Lily was like, yeah.
There's like three subcategories of furries.
And I was like, wow, really?
And she's like, yeah.
Cause your name is Doki Bird.
I was like, yeah.
And she's like, yeah.
So you're like a feathery.
And I was like a feathery?
What?
This bitch is full of shit.
And she was like, yeah, there's like a feathery, a skelly and like a furry.
And I learned so much, Lily.
I had to educate her real quick.
She was so undereducated.
I couldn't have that, man.
I couldn't have that.
Yeah.
She like educated me so hard.
I was like, oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry about the furry culture.
I just had to make sure you're aware.
I care, you know?
Oh, thank you.
I'm so happy that you like cared about me so much.
I'm like, I don't think she can go on living without knowing any detail, man.
Yeah, yeah.
Like if we're going to be playing like Wolf Quest, like I had to know the subcategories.
Like how I was...
Ryan's like, this is a furry?
No.
Okay, I'm playing...
I'm trying to create my wolf right now.
I'm so sad.
They like...
There's like DLC for this game for like better colors.
And I'm like...
Ryan?
I was like, wow.
That's so nice.
I was like, give me the DLC.
I'm like, do I buy it right now?
Is that too much commitment?
How expensive are they?
How expensive are they anyway to be like different colors?
Like the DLC ones are so pretty.
Bro, they're like seven colors.
Like, man, I want to buy them.
Seven dollars to have like a different color coat?
Or a different color coat.
What a bargain.
What a bargain though.
Like I would...
I would pay seven dollars to be a blue wolf.
Yeah, sure.
You know what?
Maybe I will.
Maybe I fucking will.
Buy the entire DLC.
Do it then.
Maybe I will.
Are you a cow?
Are you a little bitch?
No, I'm not a cow.
I'm buying it right now.
I'm buying it.
I'm not even kidding.
I'm fucking doing so good.
Boom!
I agreed.
That was a bitchin'.
Did you buy the full DLC pack?
Or did you chicken out on one?
There's like three.
Oh, hold on.
There's three.
I may have chickened out a little bit.
I may have not- Buy the rest.
Maybe you like the other colors.
I mean, clearly you're going to come back to World Quest, right?
You're going to- Clearly, I'll buy some more.
I'll play some more.
It's like... it's like Nikae.
But wolves.
It's just like Nikae, yes.
It's just like Nikae.
For those who don't know, in my chat, Lily is a...
Like, not ironically, but like, she actually loves Nikae.
Dude, that's such a cool game!
I love it!
It's got beautiful, big booty anime woman.
Yeah, and then like, when you shoot the gun...
Like, wow, the gun...
I love the pudding!
I like pudding.
How much money have you spent on Nikae?
No comment.
Come on!
Wait, someone in chat rat you out?
I think Nikae is like my least spent gacha so far.
Your least?
But you stream Nikae so much!
Yeah, but it's quite free to play friendly.
I get lucky quite a bit.
Oh my god!
Okay, so like, then you won't be shy to tell me how much you spent on Nikae if it's your least spent one, right?
I...
Well, you see the skins are like, very pretty.
Why are you so scared of telling me if it's your least spent?
I mean, it's... a few hundreds, probably.
A few hundreds?
Like a day, right?
Can you imagine?
Every day I wake up, I'm like, I have to swipe my hands, they're shaking.
I'm like, I have to swipe my hands.
You're like 80% of Nikae's budget.
Yeah, it's important!
Oh my god!
Like, being a blind wolf is a DLC?
That's fucked up!
Why is it?
Why is like a disability a paid DLC?
That's so fucked up!
What the fuck?
You wanna be a disabled wolf?
I have to pay to be blind?
What is this like, capitalism shit?
Why do I have to pay to be blind?
Oh my god!
Like, I'm sorry, but blind is only for the cool people, so like, you don't have to, you know?
Yeah, yeah, you can only be blind if you have money.
I'm sorry.
That's just how it goes.
That's just how it goes, man.
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
Fuck, everyone can afford being blind!
Oh my god, the wolf house!
There's so many different wolf houses you can have!
Dude, yeah, I have like a billion voices.
I'm like, I'm overwhelmed.
I have to do the rest of my body first.
Oh my god.
It's just so much going on.
There's 48 six wolf houses?
They all sound the same!
I can have a collar!
That's so cool!
Let's go!
Well, the rich gets richer.
Oh, I can be large.
Yeah, I'll be an orca wolf.
I'll be large.
Extra large.
You'll be an extra large wolf.
Alright, I got my howl.
I just picked random numbers.
There are too many numbers.
Oh, I get big ears!
Wait, what's this?
Ear modifier.
What does that do?
Big, big ears.
I can have like... my ears can be like scratched up.
There is tail DLC.
There's tail DLC?
Having snaggletooth as a DLC?
Come on, man!
I just bought a DLC and you're telling me snaggletooth weren't part of it?
It's time to buy another DLC.
It's time to buy another.
Damn it.
Don't you want to be cool like all the other wolves?
I guess, like me, it's not a DLC though.
Don't you want to be cool?
Are you want to be a boring NPC wolf?
Or a snaggletooth?
Or a main protagonist snaggletooth?
I wanna be a main protagonist!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I can have like a collar on.
But like educational wise.
Yeah, it's so cool.
An educational collar.
An educational collar, guys.
It's for educational purposes.
Don't worry about it.
I can be a fat wolf so you guys know I'm like well fed.
Like I can do my job.
I wanna be well fed but I want this like little spaghetti tail.
It looks so stupid.
What's a cheek ruff with- Oh, I can be- Oh my god!
I'm so fluffy!
Yeah, you get to be like a little fluffy boy.
Oh my god, what's this?
Back curve.
Okay, no, it's gonna be straight.
I don't wanna have like back problems.
I don't wanna have back problems.
I don't wanna have back problems, wolf.
Alright, ooh.
Oh my god, the tail!
It's like a cat tail!
Yeah, it's so cute!
It's so funny!
There's something wrong with this.
With this one.
Alright.
It's beautiful.
Okay.
Ooh, a very fluffy- Okay, body shape.
Oh, I'm big.
I'm the alpha.
Alright.
I'm the alpha now.
On all levels except physical.
I'm the alpha.
Oh my god, you can like- Oh, okay.
We can- You can like do your stats and stuff.
You must take example 1-1.
Okay.
I don't need to be...
Strong.
Wait, no, I should be strong.
I don't need to be healthy.
I can just be strong.
I need speed.
I need- I need maximum speed.
You need speed.
Alright, I'm gonna- You know, you can be the speedy one.
I'll have the stamina and the strength.
I'll do a minus 1 on the speed.
I have so much speed, but I will just be wheezing after five steps like- My name is Doki Wolf.
I- There's a bio by the way.
I- Oh my god.
I was born- The bio.
Without a father.
My mother left me and abandoned me.
At a young age.
My mother- Thank you.
Thank you for ghostwriting this for me.
My mother abandoned me as a young pup.
Casted out by my own family.
She now roams the wilds by herself.
Let me google the plot of Naruto real quick.
Then I kissed Sasuke.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
This is good.
This is a- I figured out a really good plot, guys.
Can I put the B-movie script in there?
Yeah, you can!
Alright.
Alright, in response to the leader of- Okay, let's see.
Okay, not Naruto, but Doki Wolf.
Doki Wolf.
Unable to make friends.
Unable to make friends?!
She is always sad and lonely.
Bro!
What is this like- You don't like Mary Sue before Wolf?
This is like a fucking DeviantArt of- Yeah, yeah!
This is like a sparkle-wolf review.
Herself, a male wolf.
I mean, hello?
It's 2024.
Don't judge my male wolf.
What the fuck?
Whoa!
Don't go there!
Hey, this is my original OC.
Do not steal.
This is my original OC.
Alright.
Oh my god, W, I found you a genius.
Just a glimpse- How do I spell glimpse?
Into my dark wolf soul.
What?
Inside you there are two wolves.
Wait, what did you name your wolf?
What did you name it?
Wait, what do I name it?
My wolf is DokiWolfFPSBTV.
Sad Handjob.
The sad- What?
Inside you there are two wolves.
Sad Handjob and DokiWolf.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm picking proper names.
I'm not good with proper names.
How do I pick a proper name?
Sads- Oh my god, yes.
Sadska.
Yeah.
Okay, maybe I should call DokiWolfToe.
How do I spell DokiWolf?
DokiWolfToe.
Remember the toe, like Naruto, but- Oh!
Sadska and DokiWolfToe.
Alright.
I'll be like- Alright, no.
Okay.
DokiWolfToe is social, bold, and energetic.
What's IronWolf?
Lives on the edge, always one false move.
Oh my god, is that like the RuneScape thing?
Where they make like- What was it like the- Oh!
Yeah!
Probably, yeah.
Yeah, but this time there's a wolf version.
There's a wolf version to this.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's like Iron Man mode!
Yeah!
But for wolves!
This is crazy.
That is crazy.
This is so elaborate.
Yeah.
Okay, continue.
Oh my- She's obviously cautious, a loner, but so much energy.
Yes, we have four souls.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Should we do story mode, which is we have to raise pups, territory quest, or pack life?
I don't know which one's good.
The pack would be cool, like what if we just- what if we just do something wrong and then I just get killed?
You just get killed?
I'm pretty sure it's the same, right?
The story mode?
You- It's like establish a territory and raise pups.
Okay, wait, chat.
All you wolf quest enthusiasts, which is the best one for mission types?
Yeah, what's the best one to pick?
Yeah, yeah, which one?
Alright, I'll- How do you two breed?
We'll figure this out.
We'll find other wolves!
We'll find other wolves, what the heck?
I think Lily's the female wolf, so she can go and find some of the male wolves.
Okay.
Yes!
I'll be the dead bee wolf and I'll try to find as many, you know, as many wolves as I can to establish a pack.
We're gonna make a big pack.
We're gonna make a huge pack!
It's fucking massive, bro!
Alright, I'll do East- Okay, game name.
Um... Wolf, Ruto.
That's our game name.
Okay, do we want Easy?
Here's an accurate level!
Accurate?
What is accurate?
No, it's fine.
We don't- We don't need to have it be accurate.
I'm fine with that.
Major decisions, I decide.
Okay, set up a game with selected wolf.
Alright.
I'm setting up our- I'm setting up my wolf.
I'm creating my multiplayer and then I'll invite you in.
Let's go.
Sashkin is gonna come in.
Wolf can smell thousands of times better than humans.
Woah!
Oh my god, there's me.
A wolf's life is- I'm a fudge right now.
One thing.
Living long enough to raise the next- Wait, I'm gonna die?!
Joki Ruto is gonna die?!
Okay, to raise the next generation which will carry their genes in the future.
All else from hunting elk to defending a territory drives towards this single goal.
Now your pack, which consists of two parents and perhaps several offspring who have stayed with the family pack as adults, can try to realize this goal.
The survival of the new literal pups and the survival of your genetic code will be your responsibility.
Oh shit, okay, how do I invite you?
My bloodline ends with me.
What
happened?!
I have no family.
I am Sashkin.
Woah!
Sashkin!
My family has casted me out that I'm unable to love.
Oh my god, Sashkin, no!
Can you join my game or like do I have to- How do I do that?
Oh wait, I have to find you.
Wait, what's your username on- what's your username on WolfQuest?
Oh wait!
It should be that.
Alright, alright, let me see.
Wait, I found player...
Oh okay.
I sent you a request.
What the fuck's the request?!
You have to look at your friends or account, I think?!
Remember to save your wolf so you don't lose it.
Account?
Yeah, I saved it.
Yeah, I remember to save Sashkin.
My bank and bio.
Yes, accept!
Alright.
Waiting.
I'm waiting for you.
I'm waiting for Sashkin.
I have no friends yet.
No friends.
Friendless.
Friendless?
I have to change my bio.
I have friends now.
Maybe I can feel love again.
Oh my god, character growth!
Wait, you're not in.
I don't see you.
Yeah, am I friendless now?
Wait, I'm... Wait, wait, can you join via my... Can you join from me?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, I found you.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Create a new pack.
I'm friend and... Damn.
Alright.
I'm gonna create a new pack right now.
Now add players.
Okay.
I'm gonna add you.
I'm figuring this game out live right now.
We're doing it live!
Yeah, okay, here.
I think we got it.
Waiting, waiting.
Did you get it?
I added you to my pack.
Ah...
It's probably somewhere.
It says you're in there.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, maybe like...
Oh, maybe it just shows up on my screen.
Guys, how do I add people to my server?
How do we play together?
How do we play together, guys?
This is the most important part.
Oh, okay.
What the heck?
All you WolfQuest enthusiasts.
How do you...
Someone has to know.
Someone must have know... must have played this game for at least 50 hours.
I know you exist.
I know.
Come on.
You have to connect.
You're in there somewhere.
I know you're here somewhere.
No idea.
Damn.
How do I play together?
This is the most important part.
Imagine we fail here.
Like, this is the first difficulty hurdle.
We just fail at playing together.
We just don't even know how to join the server.
I can't do this.
Like, anyway.
Elk.
I literally made... Okay, wait.
I'm gonna return to main menu.
I'm gonna end my session.
And then I'll... I can create a new world so easily.
I have all the power.
Alright.
It never even... Oh!
Now!
I need to... to the pack.
Lily the furry.
Yes!
I would love to join Lily the furry pack.
Nice.
Oh, you go to join!
Okay, okay.
I figured it out.
Okay.
I'm in it now.
I think it just takes a long time.
No, I just... I deleted the world.
So you're not in it.
You're not in it.
I deleted the world.
I'm not in it.
Never mind.
Okay, okay, okay.
Do not worry.
I'm fixing this.
I put this on easy.
Okay.
I set up my game with selected wolf.
Okay, let me see.
What do I... Okay.
Doki, Ruto.
Alright, that's the world.
Okay, you go to join multiplayer game.
You click new game.
New game?
Join multiplayer game.
And then you should see Doki, Ruto.
I think.
Start game selected... Nope.
So you see the single player?
You change to join multiplayer world.
Yeah, I clicked something wrong.
Help!
Oh, oh.
Okay, okay.
Okay!
Stop!
No!
Let me go!
Where are you, Lily?
Where are you?
Freaking... back to main menu.
Boom!
Okay.
New game.
You guys can look at my cool wolf while we give Lily a step by step.
No, no, no.
Us.
Yeah, yeah.
Join multiplayer.
Oh, we have rules!
No profanity, Doki.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
No problem.
Please behave.
Yeah, yeah.
Remember this is a PG stream, by the way.
No profanity in my wolf world.
We don't want the admins to come in here and ban us from wolf quest, guys.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I would be so devastated if my wolf got banned.
Oh my, my hours and money.
She spent DLC money, guys.
I bought DLC.
You can't ban me.
Someone's like, this is a Christian pack.
My dad works for Nintendo and he will find you.
He'll turn off your Switch forever.
Where is Sasuke?
What server do I join?
Doki Ruto.
US East?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It's the US East one.
Oh, Doki Ruto.
Yeah, yeah.
There's only one Doki Ruto world.
Oh.
Shit.
Oh, I got Sasuke.
Oh, Sasuke!
Ah, Sasuke!
What is it?
I'm still loading.
What the heck?
What the heck is this?
You're here too!
Oh my god.
Do you have a collar on?
You're domestic.
I cannot be domesticated.
You look like a fucking dog.
You look like a collar on my father and brethren.
I've been carrying this around for years.
All right, Maserile.
You can see...
Oh my god, you look like a fucking dog.
What's wrong with your ears?
What's wrong with your fucking tail?
My fucking tail's like a rat tail.
What's wrong with your fucking ears?
Ow!
Okay, I need to look at the account.
I need to look at the...
Oh my god, what's wrong with you?
My ears are just a little crooked, man.
What the heck?
You're shaming me?
Yeah, I'm ear-shaming you, and tail-shaming you, and collar-shaming you.
I'm gonna look at the controls.
Okay, let's see.
Okay.
Oh, I can sit down?
There's emotes?
There's a head cam?
Wait.
Well, establish your territory.
Can I pee on you?
Excuse me?
Wait, it's on pee.
I just slipped a leg real quick.
Wait, wait.
Wait, is that...?
What?
I'm establishing my territory.
I'm just establishing.
Don't mind me.
Yeah, don't mind me.
I know what's my territory.
Excuse me?
I am bigger than you.
Sasuke.
You cannot win in this fight.
Wait, I can... I can sleep?
Oh my god, I'm sleeping.
Oh my god.
I'm sleeping.
Okay, what's the emotes?
Wait, there's like... play... wait.
Oh, press... hold E and you can emote.
I can roll.
Yay.
My tail wag is so gross.
I have like a fucking rat tail.
Submissive.
What is... what is submissive?
Okay, what's airplane ears?
Oh my god, I'm just like you now.
You're like me.
I can be just like you.
You know that says... oh, uncertain.
Oh, avert gaze.
What about... wait, what is the body?
There's like sniff nose.
Confident tail.
I can sniff you.
Sniffer.
Okay, wait.
I can lick face.
Wait, why can't I lick you?
I can't...
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, let's see.
I can smile.
I can sniff your butt.
Wait, are you sniffing my butt?
Wait, wait.
Wait, are you actually...
How do I... how do I...
I think it's body.
Body.
And then I like...
No, there's sniff noses.
There's no sniff butt.
Sniff nose.
Yeah, why is sniff butt?
This game is not accurate.
Maybe it's a DLC.
But sniffing DLC.
Sniffing DLC.
Alright, what is our... what even is our purpose?
We were supposed to establish territory and like raise our... raise pups.
Our purpose is revenge.
Revenge.
We need to find our Sakura.
Sakura also failed us.
Sasuke, we need to find our Sakura.
We need to find our Sakura.
She cheated on me with Naruto.
Well, well, wait.
That's, it's not cheating.
Look, you got...
It's not cheating.
Sasuke, we told you this.
This is an open relationship.
I never agree.
Alright, let's see.
Where do we go?
How do I...
Wait, no I'm the leader.
Okay, follow me.
Follow me.
It's not cheating if there are two wolves inside.
Oh my god, your price!
It's not cheating if there are two wolves inside of her!
Inside of me there is two wolves.
Yo, what's this?
Wait, quest.
We need to find a den.
A den?
Yeah.
We need to find a place to establish our territory.
Wait, where are you?
Where did you go?
I think I'm hunting something.
I'm not sure how.
Oh my god, you're hunting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
Alright.
When... hold to press... Oh, I can bite him!
How do I bite him?
Oh, okay.
She just lets me bite him.
Alright, you just press spacebar.
Oh, spacebar!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Spacebar, spacebar.
Don't worry.
I'm hunting too.
I'm injured?
What are you hunting?
I'm...
I'm hunting a fucking cat!
I'm hunting like a little fox.
A little fox?
There's like a... Dude, this cat's bigger than me.
Nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom.
Nom nom nom.
Oh my god, how much HP do you have?
I'm just biting his butt relentlessly.
Oh, I think I'm dead.
Wait, what?
No way!
Oh, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
I'm okay.
I was like, what the heck are you messing with?
Okay, I'm... You know what?
This gets cougar wins.
This cougar is way too strong.
Whoa, win.
Definitely not me.
Oh my god, you're so far.
Create a stand spot.
Make markings into stand spot.
Mark it again to boost your claim.
Wait, how do I mark something?
Pee.
Oh, how convenient.
I cannot pee on my food?
Wait, wait.
Why are you peeing on your food?
I have to mark it as mine.
It's... Yep.
That's mine now.
That's mine now, too.
Wait, I'm gonna mark this tree.
You can't do that.
I'll reclaim it.
No, no, no, no.
Too soon.
Return to reinforce the sent post and boost your claim.
Oh, I can express myself.
I can express myself.
Pag rally.
We're our wolf brethrens.
Rally achieved.
Nice.
Look at us.
We're rallied.
We're like... How do I eat this?
How do we eat this?
We wanna eat this fox.
I spent all this time killing you.
I know.
How do I eat it?
This is important.
We're starving.
Help?
Help, guys.
We need a dough.
How do we eat this wolf?
I'm hungry.
We're starving.
Can we just leave it to die?
What the...
What are you doing?
Eat it.
I don't know.
We can't eat canines.
We can't.
So we killed him for no reason?
Why can't I eat canines?
Of course I can.
I'm a wolf.
Of course I can eat canines.
Meat is meat.
I know.
Who cares?
What the...
Who cares what I'm eating?
I know.
We're leaving.
Clearly, you're not scared of a hunter as you say you are.
My bad.
My, my B.
I guess I'll kill like an elk or something.
Who knows?
What's that over there?
Is that an elk?
Wait, there's an elk.
Oh, oh, oh.
You're entering the territory of a stranger wolf territory.
If I mark it, it's mine.
Yeah, if I mark it, it's not the stranger's anymore.
Yeah, boom.
It's mine now.
Yeah, it's ours.
It's looking...
Sorry, not sorry.
It's mine now.
Yeah, it's our territory now.
Mule deer nearby.
Mule deer damage?
Wait, where the fuck is the deer?
I feel like we need a home, Lily.
Yeah, I feel like we have to find a home.
We need a home.
I don't like this.
I don't like that we're just loner wolves trying to fucking steal food.
Where the fuck... How do we establish a home?
Take over a territory.
Find scent spots in this hex.
Mark it to reduce the claim.
Then establish a home.
This game is much more elaborate than I expected it to be.
Right?
I thought this was gonna be easy.
I have to actually use my brain here.
What the heck?
Are you still peeing on trees?
Wait.
Yeah, I'm trying to find... I'm trying to find the scent spots.
How do I find...
I found food.
You found food?
Nom nom nom nom.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's strong.
He's strong.
Oh my god, he's in giant moves.
Don't worry.
We can kill him together.
Kill him together.
Can I... can I...
Go, go, go, go.
Nom nom nom nom nom.
Yeah, that's right.
There's two of us.
We're gonna go.
Yes.
That's fucking right.
Nom nom nom.
He's... he's single now.
That's good.
Let's go.
I might be dying.
I think I'm dying, Lily.
Don't die!
We will kill this moose before I die.
I have a major injury.
I fractured my leg.
I'm fractured.
Just don't be weak.
Don't have a fractured leg.
Do you not have a fractured leg?
I have a fractured leg.
I'm almost like, let's go.
It's okay.
It's half HP.
Nom nom nom nom.
Where are you?
I'm gonna die.
I'm limping.
I'm literally limping.
Nom nom nom nom.
I'll watch.
That's right.
Don't worry.
You got this, Zetsuki.
Critical damage.
You got this.
Don't worry.
I'll howl for you.
Howl.
Nom nom nom nom.
Die.
I'm gonna watch.
Oh my god.
He hit me in the head.
Do not touch my moose.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I'll sit here and watch.
I believe in you.
This is my own home theater.
This is my...
I have to go.
I have no stamina.
Oh my god.
Nom nom nom nom.
I need to find something.
Zetsuki.
I need to eat.
Nom nom nom nom.
Come.
Kill him for me.
I'm getting a fold.
Don't worry.
I'm getting it.
What is your HP?
I told you.
I'm a big chonker.
You're so...
Alright.
Don't let it get away.
I can hop out now.
I can hop out.
Let's go.
Nom nom nom nom nom nom nom.
We will eat you.
We will eat you if it's the last thing we do.
Oh my god, he's like almost half.
He's like one fifth.
I need his jugular.
Oh my god.
Come on, we're so close.
Okay, I'm fucked up right now.
I need to chill.
Never give up!
What would Zats get saved?
One more!
One more, please.
He's like 1 HP!
Come on!
Yes!
Alright, it's time to eat.
No gore, low gore, or more gore?
More...
You know what?
More gore.
Yeah.
Oh, these claws are eating our food!
It's my food.
How do I eat it?
And then press... Oh, okay.
How do I eat this?
Oh, okay.
Space, space, space.
How to remember carcass.
You may want to return to this carcass.
How to remember... Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh!
Ow!
Yeah!
Can I eat the crow?
It's not a carnivore, so...
It should be fine.
Oh!
I can like pick it up.
Okay, to rest.
Sit down.
And then pressed.
Okay, I'm gonna sleep.
Good night.
How do I eat what I picked up?
I think it's like to... If we have a den, we can like...
Like, store our food or something.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, sleep.
I'm gonna heal.
Ah, eep.
Eepy.
Mi mi mi mi mi.
Mi mi mi mi mi mi.
Is that it?
No, it's really just... We're just eeping.
Are we...
Are we... are we healed?
Oh my god, the sun is gone!
It's so dark.
Oh my god, it's night time.
Oh, we did it!
Why are we still fucked up?
That is little...
I healed so little.
I barely healed, what?
I healed like 10%!
What is this?
What is this bullshit?
We killed Amuse and this is all we get?
I still have a broken paw.
Damn.
Wait, I forgot to eat.
It's because I forgot to eat.
Oops.
I didn't eat.
How to heal.
Wait.
Oh, if you press R.
Yeah, but I didn't even eat.
Oh, it takes hunger and then...
Am I eating?
Okay.
I'm eating.
Don't worry.
Food will cure your broken leg.
We don't need medicine.
This is home remedies.
Alright.
I'm eating as much as I can.
You can use quick heal.
Yeah, you press R repeatedly.
You can quick heal.
Oh, the orange bar is our food reserve.
I'm learning so much.
See, I knew there were furries in this chat.
I knew how to play this game.
I knew it.
They know.
I knew you guys knew.
I knew you guys knew how to play this game.
You guys pretended.
I know.
I'm eating his butt.
Come on.
Alright.
I am healing now.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
I thought it was a rabbit.
Oh, no, no.
Don't kill them.
They're not food.
It doesn't matter.
I was like, wait, it's a rabbit.
I'm gonna get extra food.
Nom nom.
I sleep.
Mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee.
Mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee.
Mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee, mee.
Alright.
Are you sleepy?
Alright, we'll wake up when the sun's out.
I'm sleepy.
We need to find a house.
How else are we gonna raise pups if we don't have a home for them?
We are homeless.
What the heck?
Wait, my leg is so fucked up.
No, I'm fine here.
What the heck?
My leg.
Let's go.
Alright, alright.
Let's find a den.
We'll come back to this later.
Take a piece of me.
It's like a travel bag.
Yeah, like a travel bag.
Yeah, there we go.
Let me grab a travel bag real quick.
A doggy bag.
A little moose to go, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
Just a little moose to go.
Alright, let's find a den.
There has to be a den somewhere.
How do we sniff out a den?
I think we just have to like go around until we find a cave.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, let's go.
There has to be a cave somewhere.
It shouldn't be too hard to find, right?
Yeah.
Like all the snow, like it cannot be hard to find a cave.
It's nature.
There has to be a hole somewhere.
There has to be a cave.
That's what nature's for.
Right?
Okay.
All I see is snow.
That's all I...
It's just snow, bro.
It's just snow and trees.
What's the point of saving the environment if it's just snow and trees?
What even is the point, man?
What's the point?
Trees don't even give wifi.
I know.
Useless.
What am I supposed to... I can't store food in my tree.
I'm not a fucking squirrel.
I wanna have like pouches, like dog pouches.
Dog pouches.
Or everything in my dog pouch.
Well, you should have fucking evolved to have thumbs.
That'd be allergic to shit.
Imagine not having thumbs.
Oh my god.
Just... that's so sad.
Imagine not having opposable thumbs.
Why is it all just snow?
I need to mark more territory?
I peed on so many things.
I didn't drink enough water for this.
Like, I only have so much pee in my bowl.
Yeah!
I can't keep marking territory.
What the heck, man?
There's not enough water here for all these trees.
God, the snow is deep.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, there's so much snow.
Fine, I'll pee twice.
They're like, dude, don't pee just once.
You gotta pee twice.
I might pee twice.
Oh my god, I lost Sasuke.
Where's Sasuke?
Sasuke!
Oh!
I found you!
I won!
Oh my god, I got you!
Oh my god, okay.
Yippee!
Yay!
We're still out here trying to find a cave.
Dude, what the fuck is the cave?
Where's the cave?
I don't even know if I've been looking for a cave.
Oh my god, look at the fucking path you made.
Holy shit.
It's pretty.
I can make a penis in the snow.
Oh yeah?
Me too.
Who has the biggest snow penis?
As if you didn't do it already.
I would never do such a thing.
This is a Christian wolf server.
This is a Christian-only server.
No profanity allowed.
It's called a Willy.
It's a Willy.
It's a wee-wee.
Wee-wee.
Why is Lily so fast?
Because I had...
I like reduced my speed for strength.
I invested in speed.
I invested in strength.
I knew speed was going to be important.
Oh my god.
Where's the cave?
There's no holes anywhere!
It's just snow!
At the border?
Wait, what?
You reached the border.
You reached the border?
Oh, we're at the edge of the map?
It forced me to go back.
Holy shit.
Oh, we have to claim more territory!
Wait, okay.
Okay, we have to go back, I think.
I think we have to go back.
Okay.
We have to go back to all the stuff we peed on.
Wait, wait.
Yeah, go back to the moose.
I think I understand something.
I have to investigate real quick.
Okay, okay.
I think I'm smelling things.
You're smelling things?
I think I'm smelling.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
What are you smelling?
I don't know.
I'm following the icon to figure out what it is I'm smelling.
Maybe it's a den.
Who knows?
Okay.
What am I smelling?
Whoa, there's so many smells!
What are all these smells?
So many smells.
It's so far away.
I thought it was going to be much closer.
What the heck?
Oh my god.
Wait, why is this one so far away?
There's like a prawn horn, a snowshoe hare, a mule...
Oh!
I'm smelling so many things.
This is how it works.
Do I pee on the smell now?
Yes!
I figured out the game!
You figured it out?
Yeah!
How?
So, that was this icon on the map and I just peed on the icon.
And now...
I just peed on it.
And now it's mine.
It's just that easy, guys.
Just pee on it.
There's a kaiouri!
Yeah, I've marked it as mine.
Now I have to wait again to reinforce my mark.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me...
Okay, I'll come to you.
Alright, I'm going to pee as well.
Just in case.
Just to make sure.
Yeah, just in case.
I just need to make sure I have this post.
You know, it's like double tap, but for pee.
Double tap?
But double pee is just like...
Two beams?
Yeah!
What?
You don't have double...
I hear wolves!
Is that you?
Are you howling?
No.
That's not our wolves.
I hear howls.
That's not... We can convert wolves into our pack though.
Yeah, I'll howl back.
Where are they?
Why are they not friendly?
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't...
But if you look at the map...
I'm quite a bit away from you.
Okay.
I followed the same...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just going to keep peeing.
I'm going to...
I'm going to keep peeing.
We need more territory.
I'm just going to keep peeing on stuff.
Just keep peeing.
Oh, above 50%!
It's most efficient to let Hex drop to 30% since you can boost him to 100% one action.
On your marking trip, visit as many Hexes in a short trip as possible.
When can we have a home?
I just want to have a home and make puppies.
Like that's...
I just want to breed.
Oh, my God.
Okay, but to steal somebody's puppies, we need to find the puppy.
Yeah, I was so close to finding the walls.
Where did they go?
I heard them and then they're gone.
Where are you?
Wait, let me see if I can find you.
Okay.
Oh, Saskia's over here.
I'm going to head over.
Saskia, I'm hiding over.
Come quickly.
Family.
Oh, I think I found you.
Oh, that's our pack territory.
We have...
Oh, my God.
This is like a fucking board game.
What is this?
Oh, yeah.
What the heck?
Yeah.
Look at these tiles.
It reminds me of like fucking...
What?
Risk.
Yeah.
Damn.
This is...
This goes deep.
What the heck?
Holy shit.
You mean for...
Honestly, for two walls, having three of that is like pretty nice.
Not going to lie.
I would say so too, right?
Yeah.
We have three of these.
We have the three marked territories.
Okay, we need more wolves in this pack.
We need more wolves.
Where did the other wolves go?
Where are these other wolves?
We want to steal your children.
I don't want to steal.
Please give up your first boy for me.
Please, for us.
How are we going to start a pack if we can't steal your kids?
Oh, I found something to mic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where?
Yeah, pee on it.
Alright, me too.
I'll pee just in case.
Just in case.
Alright.
Nice.
We got it.
Okay, we have to find a den.
If we find a den, maybe there will be already kids inside.
Like a Christmas present?
Santa just brought us kids?
Yeah, yeah.
We're Santa.
We're Santa taking away the kids.
Remember, don't be naughty or Santa's going to come over and take your children.
Santa, why is your sack empty?
Don't worry, young boy.
It will not be empty for very long.
Yeah, it'll be full soon.
Just hop on in.
Don't worry, just hop on in.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't think about it.
Okay, maybe we go the right side.
Okay, we gotta...
Why is it always snowing here?
Right?
What the heck is a den?
How do I... Why can I live out of this?
All these roads, they're hibernating!
What the fuck are we supposed to do?
Right?
Where do I go?
I have to find... Okay, maybe I zoom in?
Okay, I'm gonna... I'm gonna head straight.
There must be a cave right there.
I'm gonna head straight down.
I'm not hungry anyway.
I will find... I will find a hole to make it in my home.
I thought you were saying straight down, but um...
Your walking line is anything but straight.
It's straight!
What do you mean?
It is so straight.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Yeah, that is definitely a straight line.
Oh, you're talking about...
Don't worry, don't worry.
Maybe there's something wrong with your eyes.
You know?
Maybe... No, maybe I did buy the blind eye DLC.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got blind eye DLC.
Oh, wait, there's some scents.
An oil lamp.
A cougar.
Oh, an elk herd is nearby.
Okay, we don't... Where's this red oil lamp thing?
It stopped snowing.
I don't see the red oil lamp.
That's only you.
Oh, you press... If you hold V...
If you press V, do you see the question mark?
Oh, yeah!
What the heck?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
I'm following it.
I'm gonna follow it.
Ground scents.
Pick up the object.
Wait, what?
Oh!
It's a collectible!
A collectible.
Oh!
How do we pick it up?
Do we just grab it?
Grab it?
You grab it?
Holds... Oh!
I just held space.
Alright, now we have a lamp.
We have a lamp!
Alright, we don't have a home, but we have a lamp.
Alright, there's a...
There's a deer right here.
Where the fuck are the holes?
If we travel hard enough, we will find a cave.
That is our...
We end stream when we find a cave.
That will be it.
We will get the cave.
We get the cave and then we end stream.
Anyway, thanks for watching.
Thanks for watching.
We have a house now.
I'm sorry, but I have a house now.
I'm better than that.
I swear to God.
I'm gonna save this game and then open the server and then have our fancy just out of the play.
I just go like, I just go like, wouldn't it be funny to check back into the game?
There's a freaking mansion.
We just open the server and I was like, We just open the server and I was like, Alright, let's...
Let's have a look.
Oh my.
A 50 hour wolf plus wolf pack player.
It would be so funny.
You think I'm bluffing?
I would do.
I've done it before.
I fucking outsourced it to my tragoons.
I'm not ashamed.
Distinguished gentlemen, welcome to my humble mansion.
Did some mining off stream.
Some casual off stream mining.
I'm pissing this.
I'm making this mine.
You're making this random piece of snow yours.
I don't know.
It was mine.
It was peeable for some reason.
I like how someone in my chat was like, why aren't you peeing?
Why aren't you peeing?
Why aren't you establishing territory?
Fine, I'm gonna pee.
Okay, peeing.
Territory, territory.
I got this, don't worry.
Don't worry, I got this.
Don't worry.
If we don't find...
If we don't find a house, I swear in the next 10 minutes, server's gonna be open.
We're gonna open this server and you're gonna help us find a house.
Dragoons and... wait, what are your fans called?
They call themselves shrimps.
Dragoons, shrimps, unite.
Find Lily and Doki at cave.
Find me a cave, young ones.
Babies!
Now make babies for us.
The shrimps and the dragoons.
The shrimp goons.
Create the shrimp goons.
Create.
Oh god, it went by the shrimp goon cave.
What the heck?
We require shrimp goons now.
Shrimp goons.
How the heck do I find... surely there is a system as to how to find a cave.
Surely there is.
Wait, wait.
First we have to pee on this tree before someone yells at us.
Let me pee on this tree real quick.
I don't wanna get yelled at.
You can't see it but I peed.
I peed, I swear.
Alright, alright, alright.
Let's see.
Oh, look at our territory!
Now we have four hexagons.
Did we make it?
Yo!
I don't know what we're doing.
We expanded!
See, child, we peed.
We peed.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Abandoned burrows made by wolves, foxes, and coyotes just need to be expanded to your needs.
Okay.
We have to find...
Okay, then what is it?
We have never seen holes before.
What do you mean?
I'm looking for holes everywhere.
There is no holes.
There's no holes anywhere.
Keep peeing, ducky!
Okay!
I'm gonna keep peeing!
Pee!
Oh my god.
How do I have all this water?
Too soon!
So it's like you need a...
You got a min-max.
Min-max to piss me.
What the fuck?
You mean min-max.
Alright, alright, alright.
Okay, fine.
I'll pee on this next tree I find.
Right here.
That should be a hexagon.
Boom.
Alright.
Get peed on.
Here you go.
Wait, what is my purple bar?
What is your... Yeah, what is...
Is that a pee bar?
What is that?
What is it?
What is the purple bar?
What is the purple pee bar?
Oh, it's the rest bar.
It means we will need rest when it's too low.
Oh, I have to eep.
Alright.
I'm gonna make sure I pee on all of this just to be sure.
I'm making it mine.
It's ours now.
How do I save my game?
There's so many questions.
Please.
Oh, wait.
There's a fox.
If I scare him, maybe he will lead me to his, like, burrow.
Oh, that's true.
Make him take us to his kids.
We don't have wolf kids.
We just have, like, fox kids.
He just adopted them.
He adopted the fox.
We will raise them to be a wolf.
Exactly.
Holy shit!
Look at all these trees!
He's so fast.
That's right.
Run home!
He's so fucking fast.
Take us to your children!
Alright, here.
I'm gonna pee on this too, real fast.
This entire game is just us fighting trees.
It's just...
Oh my god.
It's a pee simulator.
It is, yeah!
Wait, okay.
How do I...
I'm gonna see if I can open the server.
How do I open...
We want babies!
We want to have puppies!
We want shrimp goons!
We need the shrimp goons!
How do I save this game?
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, save game!
I'm saving game.
Found it.
Okay, did I... Okay.
Shrimp goons.
Help us.
Please, shrimp goons.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna remake the lobby.
Help us.
We're so lost.
Okay.
I'm gonna return to the main menu.
I'm gonna end the session.
Yes, yes.
Open it up.
We're gonna open it up.
Open the gates up!
Alright, shrimp goons!
Alright, alright.
Set up game.
100%.
It's public now!
We can have three shrimp goons in here!
Let's go!
Alright.
Okay.
I'll do no chat just in case.
Just...
Just to be safe.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Join, join before the shrimp goons get in first.
Join!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Shrimp goons!
Join, join!
No, no!
Don't join!
I didn't create it yet!
Do not join!
I joined!
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, we're fine.
Wait, where are you?
Sasuke!
You're here!
Okay.
Yippee!
Alright, shrimp goons.
Oh my god!
There's already wolves here!
Yo!
Let's go!
Alright, teach us!
Teach us, MC!
Teach us!
How does this work?
My leg has been broken for a while.
Be submissive.
I am the alpha.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Be submissive on your knees.
Lie down!
Do it!
That's right!
Lie down!
And show me your belly!
Show me your belly!
Show us your belly!
Sniff my butt!
Go ahead, sniff my butt!
Where's the submissiveness here?
Where's the... what the heck?
Oh, that's freaking great!
That's right!
Yeah!
We have our pack.
This is our pack now.
I am the alpha that teaches us how to play the game.
I am dirt and ditzy.
Let's go!
I am!
I know I disable chat, but like...
Show us how to play without talking.
You may be peed on once you find us a beautiful home.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's pee on all of them to make sure they are territory.
I peed on them.
Yeah, yeah.
First pee, and then pee.
So immersive!
We're so immersive!
Woooo!
Now find us a home!
We want a home right now.
Find us a home!
Okay, follow dirt!
He knows what to do!
He's running in the directions!
Dirt knows!
Look at that confidence throwing at him!
I know it!
That's when you know this guy has 50 hours on WolfQuest Anniversary Edition.
That's when you know!
That's right!
Dirt knows!
Go, go, go, dirt!
Go!
You got this!
Yeah, you got this dirt!
Find a safe place to sleep!
We need puppies!
We need shrimp goons!
When a shrimp and a dragoon like each other very, very much.
Wait, who's the bottom?
Is it the shrimps or the goons?
I mean, it's in the name, so...
It couldn't be more obvious!
Dirt, where is our home?
Where is our home?
Okay, Ditsy is so far away.
This person did not invest in speed.
That's for sure.
They are not speedy.
They are not speedy at all.
I feel like...
You know, it would be fucked up if Dirt actually doesn't know what we're doing and he's just running...
He's just tagging along.
He's like, why are you guys following me?
Don't worry, he must know what he's doing!
Oh damn, Fang got a kill!
Okay, okay!
He's just going for it!
Go, Wolf!
Go, Wolf, go!
Oh, I'm following Dirt.
You've gone far too long without sleeping.
Oh shit, guys, I'm gonna sleep.
I'm EP too.
Body heat!
Grab me the body heat!
Me, me, me, me...
Look at all these...
Everybody just stops on the tracks to sleep.
Just... come sleep!
Sleep!
Guys, the sun is still up, why are you guys not sleeping?
The sun is up, what the heck?
Go sleep!
The alpha says sleep!
It's the middle of the day!
What the heck?
Go E.P.
Go sleep!
What are you doing?
I'll kick you out if you don't sleep.
That was quick!
Sleep or kick.
I shall sleep.
And then listen real quick.
There we go.
Oh shit, is that food for me?
That's right.
Feed the alpha.
Fan, put that food down right now.
Put that food down.
Right now.
I'm hungry.
He just shook his head.
No way!
Oh my god!
You bitch!
I can replace you.
How do I express myself?
Snarl.
Yeah, yeah, snarl.
Feed or kick.
Airplane ears?
Wait, my ears are already airplane.
How do I un-airplane my ears?
You were born like that.
I was born... I'm a natural airplane-er.
Wait, what happened to dirt?
Yeah, wait, where's dirt?
Where the fuck is dirt?
Oh my god, dirt is the one that knows where the fucking holes are.
Dirt, where are you?
He has the whole location.
No, dirt, come on.
No, where's dirt?
Wait, where is dirt?
Oh, dirt found a home!
Wait, for real?
Yeah, he found a home!
Where are you?
Yo!
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I'm behind you, I'm behind you.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Dirt found it.
It's like straight down.
Dirt tower, bang!
That's your fang and MC.
I see it.
You guys could never live up to dirt.
Dirt MVP.
You guys could never.
Yeah, you guys could never live up to the expectations we have now.
Dirt has such bars, you wouldn't comprehend.
Yeah, you wouldn't comprehend.
This is the standard now.
This is our proud child.
This is...
whoa!
Oh my god, this is it!
This is... you know what?
That's a hole?
How do we get in?
How do we... dirt, you know what?
Dirt.
That's what I expected from a collared wolf.
From a collared wolf.
From a fucking collared wolf.
You're just never meant to be wild.
That's the king, right?
Show me your belly.
How do I make it mine?
Do I pee on it?
You're gonna pee on it?
Okay.
Me too, I should.
Pee on the house to make it nice.
You're just not like us.
You're not savage enough like us.
Wait, did you just eat the...
I ate the whole thing!
What the heck?
I guess I was hungry or shit.
Holy shit, you were hungry.
Holy shit.
So how do we...
Let me look at the map real fast.
Is that our den?
Is this ours?
Show all the...
Yeah, it is!
It's ours!
Is it ours?
Make this our territory, guys.
Start peeing.
Start peeing around the trees.
Sorry.
Wolf slay!
Peek everywhere.
That's because I said collared wolf.
Guys, wolves, please.
The wolf community, do not cancel me.
Do not cancel me.
On a collared...
I cannot believe Doki Bird makes one of these collared wolves.
She has no idea where this came from.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
She doesn't know the meaning behind it.
I'm sorry!
I'm just an uncolored wolf.
I don't know.
Cut her some slack.
She doesn't know better.
I'm not wearing a collar.
I don't know.
It's ours.
We did it.
It belongs to us.
Is it belongs to us?
This is our home now?
It is belongs to us.
Oh my god.
All of us.
This is our home.
We did it.
We complete the quest.
So how do we get pups?
Now four weeks.
Your pups are too big.
Okay guys, shrimp goons.
Shrimp goons come over here.
Shrimp goons.
Make pups.
We have another request.
Now make the puppy.
Make a puppy.
Come here and make a puppy.
Make a puppy for us to see.
Wait, who is this?
Wait, he doesn't have a name anymore.
Who is this wolf?
Wait, you have a name?
Yeah, it's Ditsy.
Oh, I accidentally pressed N.
I pressed N and it's gone.
Immersion mode.
Oh my god, it makes me so immersed.
Let me look at the controls.
Let's see.
How do we make a puppy?
How do we make the puppies?
I thought when we put two puppies together it would just work.
Is there more to that?
Done.
Is there more to that than we expected?
What the heck?
This isn't everything?
That's not it?
There's more?
Yeah.
There's more.
What do you mean this isn't everything?
I can't believe you guys don't have bios.
How are we supposed to know your story?
Where's your bio?
What's that?
I'm reading it.
Only Sasuke and Doki Wolf FPS VTuber has a bio.
Why is there no bio?
You don't take this game seriously.
Yeah, you guys don't take this.
You're not as immersed as us.
Give us...
PMR things.
We need more hexes.
Sasuke and I are just gonna have these assets on while you guys pee.
Just keep peeing while we chat.
While we chat next to our home?
Failed RP.
Go pee!
We peed it up.
Breeding in bio.
I'm ready to make puppies.
It's okay.
I'm ready for puppies.
I feel like I've matured enough.
We've like outsourced it.
Yo, I love my food!
Put that down!
I'm hungry!
Your alpha is hungry.
That's right.
Show me your belly thing.
Come back!
Belly diet.
Show me your belly.
How do I make my tail go up?
Wait, that looks so goofy.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
That looks so fucked up.
It's my antenna so it can't see me.
Oh my god.
It looks so stupid.
I like how we're like...
We like outsource the help now.
We don't even do it.
This is the goal of being a streamer.
Yeah, like we get food now.
We have a home.
We get food.
We get territory.
Yeah, and then all we have to do...
Look, we can't get another piece.
They got us another hexagon?
Yes!
We have the bottom one.
Oh my god.
Ditsy, what are you doing?
Why are you still in this hexagon?
Leave this hexagon and go pee.
Go pee.
We need more hexagons.
More places.
Go pee.
We need like...
8 out of 15.
I can't do quick maths.
Quick maths.
We need 7 more hexagons.
Ditsy, leave.
What the heck?
It's in the quest.
If you press M...
Oh.
If you press M and you see establish your territory, it tells you how many hexagons you need.
Ah.
I see.
4 hexagons?
Come on.
Hop hop.
We want more.
We gave you guys 4 hexagons already.
So it's up to you now.
You started with like 3.
We traveled to this area to have a future for all you shrimp goons.
We made this happen.
We made this happen for you shrimp goons.
You should be grateful.
Yeah.
Back in our day, we didn't even have hexagons to start off.
Back in my day, we had to pee multiple tons of water for one hexagon.
Yeah.
Nowadays you piss 2 trees.
Now you guys have it so easy.
It's so easy.
No one wolf.
We have to have a known wolf?
This wolf was known to you.
He's now known to us.
Okay.
How do we... Can you give him a nickname?
Alright.
What is his name?
He's like a...
He's from... How do I have nicknames?
1405.
Oh, you go to known wolves and then you type his name.
Oh, known wolves.
Why don't we name him?
Why don't we name 1405 wolf?
Let's see.
That's a good question.
UTI.
What?
Why did it actually change?
Where did I see it?
Oh my gosh.
It's global.
No way.
No!
Oh no!
Alright.
This one...
We have two more to name.
I need to remember to see other puppies.
And then... Oh wait.
That's it.
Wait.
Is it... Oh wait.
That's the male.
Okay.
Oh, M is male.
M is male.
Okay.
Let's see.
Take back for puppies.
There you go.
Alright.
We gotta get that one.
Take back for puppies.
We gotta claim this one.
Alright.
Here we go.
Do it one more time.
We gotta get that...
Guys!
Bring that wolf to us.
We request that wolf.
Not the UTI one.
Not the UTI, the puppy.
Not the UTI wolf.
We wanna take that wolf's puppies.
Puppies!
Find her home!
And take her puppies!
That's all we want.
We just forced her over.
It's okay.
We just want a puppy!
We take care of it.
I promise!
We just want... Yeah!
We're better parents!
We're better parents.
Look at this.
We can... We're such better parents.
We have an oil lamp!
Come on!
Yeah!
Do they have an oil lamp?
I don't fucking think so!
Take her puppy.
I need her... Take her puppy.
Okay, guys, remember.
We're taking this wolf's puppies.
That's all we want.
Get the puppy!
Have they claimed more territory?
Ditsy, what are you doing?
There's like two hexagons next to you!
What?
What are you doing, Ditsy?
Are you all peeing?
You've been in that hexagon for so long!
Why can't you be more like dirt?
Visit.
I think Ditsy...
Let's go to Ditsy.
Ditsy needs some.
Are we going the right way?
I have no idea what the heck is Ditsy!
Okay, I'm looking.
Yeah, yeah, this way, this way.
Ditsy, I swear.
If we hit that hexagon before you make that hex the ours...
I swear...
We're gonna kick you out.
There's gonna be consequences, young man.
There's gonna be consequences for your action.
Oh, wait.
I need to sleep.
Goodnight.
Oh shit, me too.
No, don't leave me alone!
Goodnight.
Okay, wait.
I forgot to sleep.
What was the button again?
Zed.
Zed?
Okay.
Sleep!
Everybody sleep!
Wow!
Who's that?
Who's that that popped up next to us?
Wait, what?
Somebody popped up next to us.
Who the fuck is that?
I don't have one.
Wait, do you have like a ghost ball or something?
Ghost ball that showed up.
Holy shit.
Hello there, mother.
Mother.
Nourish me.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Nourish me, mother.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Someone's not sleeping.
Who is not sleeping?
There will be consequences.
Who's not sleeping.
You think I won't know if you're not sleeping or not?
I- I- I will...
Don't make me pull up the mat.
We will find out.
We have spies everywhere.
Oh my god, now the day is going down!
Yippee!
What a beautiful night sky.
Gone.
Is that Ditzy?
Oh, Ditzy is here.
Oh, my leg is healed!
Okay, that was Ditzy next to us.
Ditzy.
You didn't claim that other hexagon!
You're running away?!
How dare you!
You wake up and you just run?!
You have a trail!
We can find you!
I can smell you from a mile away.
We're gonna supervise your work now, Ditzy.
We can't judge like... yes, okay.
Nice arc on that stream.
Yes, yes.
Alright, we're gonna... Alright, Ditzy, we're gonna be your supervisors.
Ditzy, I swear to god.
If we get the hexagon, we're gonna be your supervisors.
You're gonna be here and you're not peeing.
Okay, nice.
Good pee.
Ditzy, stop!
Ditzy, stop right now!
Ditzy, stop right now, Ditzy!
Your supervisors are here.
Okay, nice.
Alright, Ditzy, come over here.
This tree.
This tree right here.
Ditzy, get back!
Wow.
Minus points?
Minus points right there?
Yeah, minus points right there.
I feel like we can... we can...
We can get another shrimp goon here whenever we want, Ditzy.
So, prove your worth and pee on this tree right now.
Pee on it.
Right now.
Oh, hey, food.
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
You can have it.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Nice.
Alright.
Good job, Ditzy.
Alright, that's like a... Decent form.
Decent form, yeah.
Decent form, but like, honestly, you have to raise your leg like this, okay?
Ditzy, like, remember.
This is how you actually pee on... Like this, Ditzy.
Yeah, like this.
Like this.
Yeah, like...
That's right.
Show them how it's done.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're the professionals here.
We started this company.
This company.
Welcome to Shrimp Goon Incorporated.
Shrimp Gooning Inc.
This company was built from nothing.
Did you see?
You're peeing.
You're peeing on nothing.
You're just marking the empty...
Yeah, you have to pee on trees.
Oh, wait.
That's my food.
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
Good job, Fang.
Nice treat.
Seven out of ten, I would say.
Wait, wait, wait.
The leg needs some work, but otherwise...
You're getting there, Ditzy.
You're getting there.
He's learning.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
I love our intern Fang who keeps feeding us food.
Yeah.
It's like an Uber ride.
He's like, Uber Eats here.
Uber Eats.
He's the one that brings the boss like an apple every day.
Yeah.
Ditzy, why can't you be more like...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wolf fight.
Whoa, whoa.
It's UTI.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
They're killing Fang.
You must submit.
We gotta see.
Submit to us.
Submit.
UTI, submit.
Take our puppy.
We need to get...
Help.
My butt.
Don't worry.
There's more of us than them.
That's right.
There's...
No, no, no.
Our three is bigger than their three.
I got this guy.
Don't worry.
Kill.
Like you're just howling while we're trying to kill.
Don't mind me.
We're just howling.
UTI, get UTI and then we follow puppy.
We follow.
We need to get puppy.
We need to get a female.
We got you.
We need you to take her puppy.
Take a puppy.
UTI, get over here.
UTI.
Get over here.
You can't run away forever.
Forever... I'm the alpha.
So I was like, don't get UTI.
Don't get a UTI, that would be bad.
How do I make puppy submit?
Come on puppy, submit!
Join our pack!
Rami's just running!
Come on, you can't...
Stop running, join us!
Join!
Show us where your puppies are!
Take our puppies!
Oh, I got him!
I got him, that's right, UTI.
No, no, he's still running!
I got UTI, yes!
No, I mean, not actually got UTI, but...
Not actually, but like almost.
Look, look, in any other way...
I can't see you chasing UTI!
Is our puppy injured?
Yes!
Yes, submit!
Submit!
Submit to us!
Submit, submit, my body language!
I have to be like...
Voice, I have to be like...
UTI down!
Go home!
UTI down.
Oh my god, we have the territory now too!
Wait, wait, I need to start peeing.
Okay, okay.
We need... this has to be like full yards.
Nice.
Alright.
53%, nice.
Bring us to your puppies.
Where's the puppy?
Where's your puppy?
If you don't bring...
If you want your puppies to live, you bring us to them.
Wait, I thought they were supposed to live!
What do you mean?
I mean, if we kill her before she tells us where the puppies are, then we'll just die.
No, come on.
Bring us to your puppies or join our pack.
Join our pack.
Come on, join us.
No, we've reached the edge!
She's gonna get away!
No!
She actually made it...
No way!
She made it back!
We got...
She has to come back sooner or later.
She'll...
Sooner or later, she will cross...
We're watching.
She will cross paths with us again.
We will...
You cannot get away from us, the Shrimp Goons Incorporated.
Shrimp Gooning Inc.
Let's go.
Taking puppies since 1999.
Oh, my God.
1999.
You'll come back.
Get your puppies over!
You'll be back, don't worry.
You'll be back.
We can wait forever at the edge!
Sooner or later, you'll have to leave the edge.
Your little territory!
It's expanding!
Oh, my God, look at us go!
I see you.
How many do we need now?
We need...
Three more!
Three more guys!
Let's go!
Is it?
Go forth!
Give us that territory!
We need three more!
Keep peeing!
I see you at the edge!
Go to that blue one!
Right now!
Wait, did I just hear another wolf?
Did you?
Okay.
That was a wolf I can briefly unlike my compas.
Oh, maybe... do we see a known wolves?
No, we don't.
Oh my god, they're dead.
They're like... did you see that?
Click on known wolves!
Oh god!
They're just dead!
Holy shit!
Oh my goodness!
Look, that was on them.
They did that, not us.
They were in our... okay, Fing.
They made me do it!
Fing, I am giving you a new job.
I am delegating.
Go find us...
Fing, you cannot say no to this.
You cannot say...
By joining this server, you've signed the contract.
You knew what you were getting into.
Yeah, you knew what you were getting into.
Find us another den.
That is your job.
That is your purpose.
Now go.
We don't need Uber Eats anymore.
We're cutting costs.
We're cutting...
It's den now.
We're delegating the job.
Go!
Go, Fing!
Find us more...
It's Uber rehoming.
Yeah, we don't need...
Look, we spent too much money on Uber Eats.
We have to cut down, man.
Yeah.
It's not cheap.
Yeah, Uber Eats has realized that, like, we've been paying, like, 30% tip each time.
We gotta cut down.
They were like, yeah, nah, I don't know if it's profitable.
Yeah, maybe...
I kind of have to disagree here.
Maybe ordering out every day was not a great idea, Lily.
Maybe we should start cooking.
Maybe we should...
But cooking takes time and effort and skill.
Yeah, but cooking is like $10 versus $50 each day.
Maybe we can cut costs somewhere else.
Like what, Lily?
Like what?
Like medical bills or something.
I don't know.
Like what?
Just fuck the UTIs.
Then...
Who cares?
You can do it.
You can manage.
What if...
What do you mean?
Our company's gonna go under if we don't cut costs.
Also, we need to sleep.
I'm yeepy.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
It's company sleep time.
It's company sleep time, everybody.
Go ahead.
Go to bed.
Oh.
Sleep or perish.
Why is the sun still up?
My mandatory company sleep time, guys.
If I open my eyes and I see some wolves being awake, you're gonna have a bad, bad time.
I swear.
I...
We took this block of time in our schedule for mandatory company sleep time.
And you are wasting company's time right now by not sleeping.
You have to sleep.
This is why we have to cut costs.
Do you want me to remove company sleep time?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, that's her!
Come back, puppy!
No!
What the fuck?
Why did she like pop up next to us?
She was like, oh, you're nice and vulnerable and lonely.
She was like, peek-a-boo, peek-a-boo.
You guys wanted to take my puppy.
At this point, she was just flexing, bro.
She's like, oh, I can't sleep.
You can't catch me.
Oh, you can't catch me.
Here's the edge again!
Oh, you made it out.
Boom!
Alright, I'm gonna pee more.
We need to pee more.
It's not fully ours, yes.
It has to be fully ours.
It has to be more yellow.
Wait, I'll pee on the animals.
More pee.
Bang, did you find...
Bang, did you find a den?
Why are you just peeing?
That's not your job.
Your job is to find a house.
Look, pee.
Performance review is like in two days and it doesn't look really nice right now.
At this point, the best we can do is give you a nice reference for your next job.
Bang, if you don't find a den by the end of this day, that performance review ain't gonna look so good, Bang.
You're gonna have some holes in your resume.
Yeah, you might need to update your resume soon.
I'm just gonna say, your ability to be a wolf is not looking so good.
On a scale from one to wolf, you're... I don't know.
I don't know, you're more like a fucking dog.
A domesticated one.
Not like the good kind of domesticated dog, more like a fucking chihuahua.
Fucking little rat.
Yeah.
One more, we need one more.
Hex!
I'm...
We need one more hexagon and we need three more caves.
I'm trying to unlock this hexagon and now this cat is like... on my ass.
Go away, shit.
Just run.
Just run away.
I want this territory.
I want this to be mine.
Bro, what's the cat gonna do?
It's a fucking cat.
That's right.
Yeah, kill him.
No cats allowed.
Fuck you, cat.
Nom nom nom nom nom nom.
Alright, I'm peeing.
I'm gonna make this hexagon mine.
You cannot run.
I'm faster.
Alright.
How's this sound?
Well, you better be faster.
You fucking invested in speed.
No, no, no, no.
My speed and my spin is taking off.
Yes!
I knew it was worth it!
Did you kill the cat?
No, but I'm catching up to it.
He's laughing.
He caught up.
I'm catching up to the cat.
Come here, kitty.
Kitty, kitty, kitty.
Psst, psst, psst, psst, psst.
Why do we still only have one home?
Only Dirt found us a home.
No.
I knew Dirt was like the... I knew hiring Dirt was the right call, Lily.
When I saw that resume, I knew he was gonna...
Yeah, Dirt is the one.
He'll be very valuable to the company.
Yeah, Dirt was gonna make Shrimp Goon Incorporated a rising star.
He knows what's up.
Someone said... Someone... Apparently, Dirt's a dragoon and they're like... Dirt was in the chat and he told us he had 200 hours on WolfQuest.
Holy fuck!
Dirt knows!
Oh my god, Dirt is a gamer!
He's a knower.
I just joined MNOLA.
We knew we had a couple 50 plus hour ends.
I knew too.
I knew it.
Those who joined instantly in WolfQuest Anniversary, they've... they were already playing the game before.
They were playing long before we played.
Yeah.
Dude already had it like loaded up before the stream even started.
They knew.
They fucking knew.
You were just counting on playing being like, Wade, they're playing my game!
They're playing my game!
Let me leave my... my 200 hours on WolfQuest.
I'm gonna go to server real quick.
Let me leave my family real quick.
Alright, I pee.
Do we have 15 hexagons now guys?
Do we do it?
Yippee!
We still need one more!
I killed the cat.
We need... guys!
Dirt!
Dirt, I know I can trust you.
Find us another home, Dirt.
Fanning doing quite a great job right now.
Hey, go shadow Dirt and learn how to be a real wolf.
Go shadow Dirt?
Learn how to be a good one.
We're giving you one more chance.
Shadow the real wolf.
Only this way you will one day become a real wolf.
Yeah, one day you'll be just as good as a wolf like Dirt.
Fan, we don't need food!
We're all full!
I'm claiming this.
I'm claiming this so hard.
That's okay.
That's why...
That's why Fang is just an intern.
Pleasure watching you.
Look, Fang.
I hate to break it to you, but like...
That college reference...
That extra credit ain't looking so good, Fang.
You got it.
I don't know about the extra credit anymore.
Fang, you got it.
Fang is feeding Dirt.
I'm feeding Dirt right now.
You know what?
That's a good intern.
Intern, show your belly to Fang.
Fang, show your belly to Dirt.
Or to me.
Show your belly.
That's right.
Show it.
Or I'm gonna growl.
We have 15 out of 15 hexagons!
Oh, we did it!
Let's go!
We did it!
We just need to discover dance.
We just need dance.
Alright.
Alright, our main goal.
We don't end stream until we have puppies.
That's our goal.
We need the puppies.
We need.
That is our...
We have to have...
I will...
I will make the 24 hour thing.
If I have to.
I need puppies.
We must be the worst WolfQuest players out there if it takes us 24 hours.
I appreciate this not taking 24 hours.
I think it's 48 if I have to.
Dirt, stop hunting.
We need...
We need them dead.
I'm bored.
You know what?
Okay, no.
That's fine.
Wait, you're gonna eat for yourself?
What about me?
I'm the alpha.
I'm following Dirt right now.
Wait, where are you?
I'm at the border.
You're at the border?
We don't even know where you are.
We don't need any more hexagons.
I am looking for a den.
Alright.
So we can make babies.
I'm following Dirt.
I need to make sure he is on track.
I need to make sure he knows what he's doing.
I'm his supervisor.
He used to be supervised all the time.
He's that one annoying co-worker who gets nothing done.
It's like, yup, gonna have to supervise Dirt again.
I'm the supervisor that gets paid twice as much as Dirt for just watching.
For how many hours?
For 5% of the work!
For only 5% of the work, I just watch him.
You show up late, you sit around on your chair watching a bit.
And now I'm like, whoop, there we go.
Gonna go on my Ferrari now.
Bye, guys.
Vroom vroom.
Oh, guys, you guys didn't get invited to the company dinner with the CEO?
Man, that sucks, guys.
That's too bad.
What the heck.
You gotta earn it like me.
Yeah, you gotta earn it like me.
Guess you didn't do it, you know, you didn't work hard enough this company.
Yeah Yeah, you know maybe next year.
Oh my gosh.
I got caught up on for the company promotion.
Oh my god guys I'm guys just like me if you work just as hard I knew my hard work would pay off
I knew supervising supervising is a very hard job guys.
It's so hard.
It's so difficult I mean like Stan It's so hard like I have to like watch dirt over here and like I could be doing other stuff right now But instead I have to make sure it does a good job.
Yeah, how's what I know if dirt's doing a good job or these half-assing it Valuable assets to this company by making sure dirt is working overtime Look keep getting something because this happened to me
To all of us at some point.
This is why we know it so well Bro I came here for escapism not be reminded of my wagey life
It hits so close to home man what the heck We're just wolves guys We're just wolves It's just a coincidence that is like it's like a wagey
Yeah, I'm angry now Imeting now Wait you let me add a market you Where all the tens how can they be light even fine tom?
How could it be lack of dense its nature?
Right, it's mother nature Which is because everywhere gave me hole?
Give me hole advice why?
Just make a hole.
Like, why do I have to look for one?
Just make one.
I know!
We can dig a hole together!
Right?
Just dig, dig, dig!
Dig, dig, dig!
Where's our dig button?
Don't worry.
Yeah, where's my dig button?
Dirt, I know you can be better than this, dirt.
Come on.
I know you're limping and you have a broken leg, but this is important.
But come on, I have to, you know...
Sometimes you just have to push through, you know, just like me.
You need to give us 150% with that broken leg.
Right there.
This company is like a family.
Which I will remind you when I get you a pint of pizza.
Pizza party!
We're a family.
It's okay, we have pizza now!
Don't worry, we have pizza.
We have pizza!
Welcome to Shrimp Goons Incorporated!
Don't worry.
Your overtime will be paid nicely in pizza time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's cold and cheap, but don't worry about it.
The cheese is like fully hard on you.
It's like, we don't even buy it from a pizza place.
We go to like a supermarket for those refrigerated pizzas.
Fucking oven pizzas.
Yeah, yeah.
And if we get like a used pizza box from like Domino's.
Like fresh Domino's pizza!
Fresh Domino's pizza!
It just doesn't look like Domino's pizza.
What the heck?
What are you trying to say?
It's in the pizza box.
What do you mean?
I'm saying I'm lying.
What the heck, man?
Are you trying to say your bosses are lying to you?
After everything we did.
After everything we've done.
Wow.
Yeah, we opened the server for all of you guys.
It's almost like you don't appreciate our hard work as supervisors.
I know!
Look at all these hexes we got for you.
All 15 of them was done from Lily and I.
And all we asked for you was a den.
A home.
A place to call home.
We just wanted a place to call home.
And this is how you pay your family?
Yeah.
We took you in, gave you shelter, gave you work.
Yeah!
Where is... Oh, it's E.P.
time.
I found a new dog.
Wait, a new dog?
It's E.P.
time though.
I found two.
E.P.
time.
Wait, you guys all spawned in with me.
Wait, what the heck?
What the fuck?
What was that?
That was trippy.
What?
That's right.
That's when you know I'm alpha.
Don't even the snow part it.
Like, what the heck?
Yeah.
This is when... There you go.
Oh my god, there's all of us.
Me, me, me, me, me, me.
I'm being cute.
Look at us.
This is so cute.
Oh my god, look at all these wolves.
Look at all these wolfies.
Oh my god.
It's day time.
Yippee!
Yay!
Wait, we are?
We are!
Guys, we did it!
We're next to a den.
What the heck?
We did it!
How do we?
It's right...
Wait, wait.
We have to kill her.
Okay, guys, come on.
Come on, fight.
Surround her.
Oh, we have to fight first.
This is our...
Surround her.
This is our den.
Our puppies will be here.
This is our... Yeah, this is our children now.
This is for our pups only.
Our puppies.
Don't let her go.
How is she still half HP?
There's literally four of us.
Right?
Like, she's strong.
Bro, how old is she?
That's not a wolf.
That's a cougar.
She can pack a pond, bro.
Whoa!
That's fucking right.
That's our home now.
That's right.
Okay, how do we clean this?
Our den.
Piss.
Do we...
Too fast.
Piss.
PP time.
IP.
IPP time.
Our den now.
Alright, Fing.
We need another home.
Fing!
You know, I'm gonna...
We're gonna splurge a little bit.
Now bring me food.
I'm ordering Uber Eats.
I would like one rabbit, please.
One rabbit, please.
Thank you very much.
Alright, 10% tip.
How generous!
A whole 10%?
No way!
A whole 10% tip if you get me that rabbit on Uber Eats.
We need two more!
Two more!
And then we'll have...
Come on, we got this!
Puppers!
Puppies!
Reveal two dens.
Okay, you established and found several.
It's time to give your pack...
It's time to give our pack a name!
How should we name it?
Oh, wait, wait.
Shrimp Goons Incorporated.
Let's go.
Yeah.
There you go.
Continue.
Oh my god!
Oh, what's this?
Okay.
You wanna keep working on territory and looking for dens or proceed to choosing a den?
You know what?
We can choose a den now.
Right?
We can choose a den.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Choose a den.
Surely.
Alright.
Remember, you must maintain it even when your pups require all your time.
The smaller your territory, the more likely stranger wolves will be tempted to come in and kill your pups!
Kill my puppies?
Hello?
You can't kill our puppies if we kill them first!
Yeah, we'll just kill them before they kill us.
What the heck?
We'll just kill their puppies.
Whoa!
Oh?
Puppy cutscene?
Your pups will be born soon.
Now that the snow is beginning to fall, we can go back to the desert.
It's time to find a good den site.
There's no need to dig a new den for yourself since there are many potential sites.
Many?
Sure.
We'll revisit the dens you discovered over the winter.
Oh, okay.
So we just go back to where we found our den.
Oh, hey.
Oh, my rabbit!
My Uber Eats is here!
Nice.
Uber Eats!
I got my Uber Eats.
Thank you, Faye.
Cavities underneath all tree roots and gaps on the large boulders.
Okay.
Alright.
You know what?
I think it was a good idea for us to go open the desert.
Yeah.
It would have taken forever.
Holy shit.
We would have figured this out on our own.
I would have also looked for something way bigger.
I was like, oh, den, no problem.
I would just look for like a huge massive cave.
How hard can it be?
Oh, is this a good den?
This is a wood and the trees providing cover will limit the ability for eagles?
The eagles can't eat our puppies?
What the hell?
They don't know how to do that.
What?
Alright.
I'm going to go with this one.
The first one I found.
Whoa!
Do you have a cut seat or is it only me?
Wait.
I think it's only you.
I'm just running around.
Okay.
What do we name our den?
I'll give you the choice of the name.
You don't want to do that.
No, no.
It's fine.
I trust in you after your UTI.
I have my full trust on you.
Well, I'm going to go with this one.
Our den should be called infected butthole.
Okay.
I'll take one word from this.
Mild infection?
I'll give you infected.
I'll give you...
Infected toe clippings.
Okay.
I'll give you infected.
I'll give...
I have a feeling you don't like my names very much.
Something gives me the feeling.
I like 50.
I like 50% of it.
That's still a pass.
That's still a pass right there.
Okay.
Infected...
Flammable lighter fluids.
Okay.
It's okay.
I already named our...
Your den is ready for post.
It will be ready soon.
Yes, go up a moon.
Wait.
Who's the mom and dad?
I placed the quest completion dialogs open.
Who's the parents?
The parents?
Yes, how do my toes...
They just like...
Do you see this?
No, my screen's just black.
There it is.
After nine weeks of gestation...
Oh my god.
Five pups are bored.
Five.
Bro, that's way too many mouths.
Blind and deaf?
Oh shi...
What?
What the fuck?
Useless.
How do we put them to work?
Are there any other things...
It doesn't work!
If they're blind and deaf!
It lets me name them.
Oh no.
Oh no, it lets me name them.
Can you name them?
That's terrible.
For three weeks, they first emerged from the dead into the sunlight.
They all dark brown, but in a few weeks their pups' coats would change.
Is that me?
Am I the...
I thought I was male!
I'm a male too!
I'm also a male!
Yeah!
Alright, I'll name one of them a dragoon.
I'll get that.
Yeah, yeah.
Lock that in.
Alright, alright.
Wait.
Oh wait.
Oh, each of us gets to name one!
Wait, are you guys naming?
Okay, okay.
Wait, we each...
We all of us made puppies together!
We all know who the mom and dad is!
Oh shit, it's my puppy, Eves!
We know who the mom and dad is!
We know who the mom is!
We know who the dads are!
We each get one!
Guys, no!
My puppy will not be eagled!
I swear!
I named the puppy.
Okay, now four weeks old, your pups are too big for the den.
As they spend their day playing to increase the affinity of your family plaque.
If they're playful, play with them.
If they're hungry, feed them.
If they stray far from the den, go find them and carry them back.
Pups mostly eat meat.
Regurgitate it by the adults in your pack.
Okay, that's your job, Lily.
Wait, wait, wait!
You can do that.
I can't wait to do that.
Someone named their puppy!
Dirt named their puppy Dirt Junior!
That's my puppy!
Where's your puppy?
Dirt Junior is so cute!
It's like my puppy died.
Wait, what?
Wait, Aqua!
Okay, I'm pretty sure the fifth puppy has to be yours.
He's got a pretty shirt.
Where's my puppy?
Is the name not good enough?
Did it die?
Where is it?
No!
Look, I'll be sweet here and name the track.
Would you fucking name your shrimp puppy constipation?
Shrimps, remember!
Which streamer actually...
Remember who cares.
Remember who fucking cares.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Chan, you like the name, right?
Time one if you like my name.
Time one if you appreciate my name.
That's my streamer.
I love how your puppy is the last one to come.
I'm about to...
He lives up to his name.
He knows what's up.
Wait, there's a fox!
Oh my god, there's danger!
There's a fox!
It's trying to eat her baby!
Get him!
Take constipation, but not the trick!
Don't take constipation!
Stop!
Don't take it!
No!
He's going closer!
Oh my god, he ran away!
He ran away!
He can't take it!
That's right!
Get the... Get the hike away!
Your pups are safe again for a moment.
Alright.
Constipation, you may stop clenching your butt cheeks.
You will learn later why.
I still can't believe it was the last one to come.
I still can't believe it.
I'm making a curse.
I chose my name wisely!
Dragoon!
Look at me!
I'm playing with you!
Dragoon!
Go play with your fucking puppy!
Tail up!
I'm sick of having...
Yay!
Look at that!
It's so cute!
What the heck!
It's so beautiful!
You're beautiful!
We're proud!
You're beautiful, baby!
We can't breathe!
We worked so hard, Lily.
This is what we've been working for since we started this company!
It's paying off!
It's all us, Dokie!
It's all us!
All us!
Woo!
Noooo!
I knew working overtime day and night at Shrimp Goons Incorporated will pay off!
Yippee!
Yay!
Someone in chat just says, you are like my aunts when they heavily drink.
I don't know if it's a compliment or not, but thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, there's a puppy cam!
You press shift and F, you get to be the puppy!
Shift F.
Oh, puppy cam!
Puppy cam!
That's you guys!
So cute!
Dragoon, get away from Aqua!
Get away from Aqua!
If you're associating with anybody, it's Dirt Jr. Dirt Jr. knows what's up.
He's the 200 hour wolf quest bro.
Constipation do be walking like this.
Okay, get away from constipation, Dragoon.
Get away... that one's special!
I'm from constipation!
We got the constipation camera!
Yeah!
Dragoon, when you grow up, you will be Alpha.
You will be the new Alpha.
You will be the new Alpha, Dragoon.
You will be...
You grow up to be a constipation's boss.
No!
You're gonna be constipation's supervisor.
He will tell you when to poop!
That's when you're constipated!
No poop breaks until five!
I can't believe it.
How dare you poop?
I'm glad we opened the server.
I definitely think we would never figure this out.
Oh, we would never.
We would never fix it.
We would have had such a hard time.
This is...
Holy shit.
Thank god.
Thank god the gamers are here to save the day while we supervise.
Wait, we can pick up our kids?
How do we pick up our kids?
If you hold space on them.
Oh my god.
Get over here, Dragoon.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Stay away from that bush.
He ain't right.
Oh my god, my tail's so ugly.
It's like a little...
Rat tail.
Just wagging.
They look like fucking cats.
They look like cats.
They don't even look like wolves.
Oh, thank you.
Cut off that.
My hips so ugly.
Fuck no!
Come back!
Vang, our Uber Eats!
What will we do about Uber Eats?
Who would feed them?
We'll feed our puppies.
Come back.
We'll feed the children.
We're supervisors, not doers.
We have worked enough in our lives.
I'm gonna outcast the whole world.
Oh, what?
Attack the boobies!
Where is it?
Oh my god, there's four!
There's five of them!
What?
Go get them out.
They're attacking our boobies!
Come back, come back.
Oh no, no.
Vang, come back!
There's a wag!
Vang, we need you!
Oh my god!
Stay away!
Not the dragon horn!
Stop!
No!
It's okay, children!
Oh my god, they're so...
Get the fuck away from the babies!
Get away from the babies!
Go!
Leave!
For the puppies!
They're in the den!
They're safe!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I like how Vang is just lying down.
I like how Vang is just chilling while there's a fucking war going on.
He's like, yeah, it's alright.
Yeah, yeah.
He's like, don't worry about it.
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
There's so many!
Leave!
Get out of here.
Run!
That is right.
They give it up.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
Nobody messes with us.
Yeah.
That's right.
Come out, little babies.
Come out, come out!
Come, come to patient on school, dragons!
I'm also gonna have riots.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hello!
Yes, dragons!
You guys live for another day!
That is so fucking cute!
When did they grow up?
When are you gonna- Oh my god!
I'm throwing up food!
We have work to do!
Oh fuck!
Come on, grow up!
Oh my god, I regurgitated food!
I wasn't supposed to- I don't know how that happened!
I just- I'm new to this.
It just happened.
Oh my God.
It's fatherly instinct.
Oh no, my instinct!
Oh my god.
My fatherly instinct!
Oh my God.
What the heck?
How do I...
Where is regurgitating from?
Oh my God.
I don't know!
It just happened!
I don't even know!
I can rest my chin.
How do I do that?
It just...
Oh, it happened again!
It's just happening!
It just keeps happening!
It doesn't stop!
Imagine just uncontrollably puke over and over.
Oh my god, I'm sorry!
Dang it, you're not supposed to see that!
That wasn't my job!
Oh my god!
Why don't you feed the children, Satsuki?
I don't have anything to throw up, I don't know!
How do I throw up?
Just press space!
Space bar!
You did it!
I'm so proud of you!
So gross!
You're now a father!
Come here!
Eat my vomit!
Come on, children!
Didn't I serve?
Dragoon, no!
Don't touch that Dragoon!
Uh-uh, constipation don't wander off too far!
Someone's gotta kick Fang out!
He's like, yup!
Fang is just there!
Fang, you're not even in here anymore!
What are you doing?
Yes, I'm eating it!
Oh, it's raining!
Oh god, it's raining!
Don't get sick!
Oh no!
Wait, we have fleas?
I'm a six percent...
We have fleas?
Wait, how do I get rid of fleas?
Ew!
Oh no, we have fleas!
Okay, our pups have to roll around.
They have to be fifteen!
Okay, wait.
How many pounds do they have to be?
Fifteen pounds!
Who's underweight?
How heavy are they?
Who's underweight right now?
Wait, Dirt Junior is not... is like starving.
Who's not feeding...
Wait, who's not feeding Dirt Junior?
Wait, just eat the vomit, Dirt Junior!
Come on, man!
Dirt Junior, eat!
What do I see?
The puppy info?
Oh, pack info?
Yeah, it's pack info.
I can't believe they have to be fifteen pounds!
They're only five pounds!
Dude, they're like not growing at all!
What do you mean?
Oh my god!
Eat!
Okay, I'm gonna eat too.
So I can feed...
I'm gonna feed the puppies.
Each puppy has a favorite wolf that they like to socialize with more often.
And I'm not on anyone's list!
Not even my own!
Not even your own child?
I am!
Oh shit!
Okay, okay.
I was gonna say, as your own child.
I'm like, how Dirt claimed two of them.
Dirt was like, yeah, I'm getting both of them.
I can't believe it!
Alright.
Okay, eat.
Eat.
Dragoon, why are you sleeping?
Dragoon.
Dragoon, socialize with me.
Socialize?
Socialize with me now!
Come on, play with me!
Wee!
Play with me!
What if I take a break from socializing with your pups?
Why would I do that?
Wait!
What the fuck?
What?
Don't kill Lily, love child!
Who is this?
They peed on my kid!
What?
They peed on my child!
What the heck?
That's fucked up!
They peed on my child!
You can't do that, do you?
You're so gross!
What the heck?
That's fucked up!
This person peed on my child!
Bro, their bio is puppy in bio.
Their bio is what?
Their bio is puppy in bio.
Puppy in bio.
What the heck happened?
It's just cause Fang got kicked out and this person sniped this bot.
They were waiting this whole time to do this.
This whole time.
Alright, TokiLilyLoveChild, go and adopt Fang's child and rename them.
Rename them.
They're your kids now.
You can have that child.
Go rename your kid.
I don't know which one.
Choose a wise name.
I don't know if it's Ivy or Aqua.
I don't know whose child it is.
But you'll figure it out.
You got this, don't worry.
Dragoon, look at me.
I don't want to take a break from socializing with my child.
Ryan, who does that?
My child has to be socially aware of what's going on.
I don't want him to be anti-social.
Please socialize.
Come on.
Don't be a freak, Dragoon.
I need you to be well adjusted to society.
Can somebody feed the children?
I don't have enough food in my stomach to regurgitate.
Can someone feed the kids?
I don't want to feed the kids.
Can someone just...
Guys, stop howling.
We need you to feed the children.
Can I throw up some more?
Wait, Ivy's gonna die from lack of sleep.
Okay, we gotta sleep.
We're gonna have to sleep?
Okay.
Yeah, we gotta sleep.
It's sleepy time.
Guys, it's okay.
The kids will be fine and we all just sleep.
Right?
They won't get abducted.
They won't get abducted when we're all just sleeping around.
It's like an eagle cacaw.
Yeah, the eagle just comes in and takes away...
Just loops one.
Oh, it's just sleeping.
Don't worry.
We'll be fine.
Guys, sleep.
Mother, what have you forsaken me?
The eagle mother.
Father.
Father, help.
Please.
Father, please.
There's an eagle.
Wake up.
Please wake up.
Who's that wolf behind us that's not sleeping?
Is that Doki, Lily, Love Child, Puppy and Bile?
Is he?
We have to... we have to... investigating, investigating.
Sleep.
We're sleeping.
The alpha requests sleep.
Excuse me, sir.
Could you please lay down and sleep?
Thank you.
Oh, no.
It'd be so fucked up if an eagle just swoops in right now.
While I'm looking at the children.
Where's Dragoon?
Dragoon?
Wait, he actually got eaten by an eagle.
Oh, there's Dragoon.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, they're sleeping.
Oh, thank god.
They're in... How the heck did you get inside?
They're inside.
Just press spacebar.
Oh.
Alright, just press spacebar.
You can see the kids.
Oh, they're so cute.
What the heck?
They're all so cute.
Alright, let's see.
We need...
Alright, they are seven pounds.
They're halfway there.
Guys, feed.
We need to hunt.
Alright, Lily, we gotta hunt.
We need a little...
Arcand regurgitate.
Yeah, we have to hunt.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Let's hunt.
Okay, I'm looking...
Let's see.
I'm in scent mode now.
Okay, I'm sniffing.
Follow me.
You're picking something up?
I'm picking something up.
Okay, I went the wrong way.
I'm behind you.
Don't worry.
I went the wrong way.
Walking the wrong way with you.
It's this way.
You got this.
Follow me.
I know exactly where I'm going.
That's the wrong doki.
I found the wrong doki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's here.
Are you following the doki Lily love channel?
Yeah, I was like way in.
Wrong doki.
It's okay.
I'm picking up the scent.
Where are you?
Where are you little rabbit?
Oh my god.
Where's the rabbit?
Where the fuck did the rabbit go?
I can't find the rabbit.
Oh!
Where?
I see.
I see elk.
I see it.
But there's a wolf.
I can't eat the wolf.
But there's elk here.
There's elk here.
Elk?
Oh, it should be.
Can I have an elk?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a lot of food that we can...
That we can like feed the children.
I'm coming.
We can't puke so much.
We can't have so much bum.
I'm going up.
I'm getting up there.
They're so fast.
Why didn't I invest in speed?
Should have went with speed.
It was a mistake.
They're too fast.
Oh my god.
I swear it's gonna take me like 20 years to get to these deers.
They're so quick.
I'm going so fast.
They're not tired.
We'll outrun them eventually.
We just have to outlast them.
Easy.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
There's no way these deers can run forever.
But you have like stamina investment.
You got this.
You got your stamina.
There's no way.
I hope somebody's protecting the cubs while we're gone.
I hope...
We come back, no cubs.
Oh god.
I hope the...
I hope the kids are okay.
Please be okay.
We're hunted.
I like somebody who's like spamming eagles.
I gave up.
They are too...
Kaka!
Oh, there's a...
There's a...
Freedom eagles.
Freedom.
Welcome to America.
This is America.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm catching up.
There's a bear!
No!
Somebody save our kids!
Guys, there's a bear on our kids!
What the heck?
Is there anybody near?
Oh, they're back.
There's people near.
It's okay.
We've had our babysitters.
Our bear.
The bear.
Oh shit.
We're coming back, children!
Oh my god.
There's a bear!
I'm so far from home!
What the heck?
Okay, wait, wait.
There's like...
I got food though.
I'm gonna eat real fast.
Okay.
My children are dying.
However...
Anyway, Daddy's hungry.
Sorry.
Daddy's a little hungry right now.
Just a little hungry.
Oh!
Oh, they did it!
They did it!
They fended off the bear!
Oh!
Oh my god.
I knew.
The shrimp goons could do it.
Dude, we were so far away from them!
Yeah, we...
Dude, those kids we're fucking dead.
We're so far away.
Yeah, thank god for the shrimp goons.
They are gone.
Because we're only alive, and we have nowhere to pay money.
Definitely our kids would have been gone.
Dude, can you imagine all this work just for them to be gone?
Because we killed a freaking deer.
We didn't even get the deer, that's the worst part!
I was so close!
Wait, I'm sniffing something.
Oh, rabbit.
You sniffing something?
Alright.
I'm just gonna hope that like fucking food comes out.
Food just jumps into your mouth.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just hoping like somebody just wants to, you know, they just don't want...
Wait, wait, I found a herd!
I found a herd!
Wait, I don't think I'm far from you.
Oh, wait, shit, I am far.
Okay, it's okay, it's okay, I found out.
I'm on my way, I'm on my way.
I found a herd of deer.
Oh my god, we're...
The kids are gonna eat so well!
Oh!
I'm on my way, I'm on my way!
No, not this way!
Okay, fuck it.
Get deer faster!
Four kids!
Okay, okay, I'm getting him.
He's like half HP.
Oh no, he's so far.
Oh, I think I see you from like the distance.
Holy shit.
I actually see you.
No way!
What?
From the distance.
I saw something like run down the hill.
My jaw!
I broke my jaw!
Lily, I need you to tag out!
I need you to tag out with me!
I broke my jaw!
I'll tag you, I'll tag you!
Oh shit, I'm so far still.
I'm so far!
Okay, it's a really big deer.
Alright, don't worry.
He's almost dead.
We gotta bring this food over.
We gotta bring the food over.
Okay.
I got him, I got him!
Holy shit!
Yo, let's go!
Let's go, let's go!
Let's feed the children!
Okay, I'm gonna go eat this real fast.
We have to eat a lot?
Yeah, we have to eat a lot.
Sasuke, come over here!
Eat your elk!
I'm coming!
You gotta be full!
Do not- I swear to God- Do not pee on this deer.
I swear!
I would never.
I swear to God.
What the heck?
I would never.
I do not trust you right now.
Don't worry, children!
Papa's got some food in the stomach!
Don't worry, dragon!
Okay, I think I'm full.
I will feed.
Okay, I'm- Oh, I can eat more!
Oh shit, let's go!
Yeah, keep eating until you're full!
Okay, I'm full.
I'll take a piece of meat.
Yo, I got a big piece!
Let's go!
Take it to feed the rest of the pack!
Yeah!
It's nice that you actually cared about like the rest of the pack because I just- I just get full and then- I was like, alright, I'm full now.
Let me go over.
Adios.
I did my job.
Feeding myself.
Someone had to do it!
These interns ate shit!
They saved our children, but come on, man.
Children!
Papa's here!
I swear to God.
Kids don't- if you socialize with my kid too much, I swear to God.
They're stealing our children!
The better dragon!
Who the fuck- Feed the child tra- The better dragon!
Wait, they're fucking- Wait, what the heck?
Wait, I haven't fed the kids yet!
I'm trying to feed.
Alright, there we go.
No, don't go back to the game!
I'm being attacked!
Where is the- Where is it?
Where?
Oh, I see them!
I see them!
They're right behind me!
Okay, you guys- You guys go protect.
I'm just gonna give them more food.
That's right.
Oh, they already gave up.
That was fast.
Wow, we did it.
Wow.
Wow, we're so good at this.
Yeah, alright.
Come out.
Come out and eat.
Eat!
Come here, constipation.
Eat.
I'm gonna be a fresh worm for you.
Shut the fuck up.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Better
dragon is like- That's like 8.6 pounds.
What were you doing?
Wait, what's the rest of them?
Mine's 8 pounds.
So, like, he's okay.
Wait, he's growing big!
How?
What the heck?
Wait, what's yours?
Yours is 7.9?
Someone's not taking care of their kids.
I might have to call wolf support.
He's constipated, okay?
I'm gonna call wolf support on you.
That's malnourishment right there.
Please don't take away from me.
Don't call wolf support, please.
I'm gonna call wolf support.
Good luck with...
No!
Don't take away my constipation, please!
I love it so much!
Ma'am?
How many times are you feeding your children?
Like, at least two.
What is that?
Two ways!
Two!
Just two!
Don't worry, it's just...
The kids don't need sleep, they need food!
They don't need sleep!
We just need to feed!
Just feed.
Dirk Jr. Yes, yes, yes!
Eat, eat, eat!
Good job!
Yes!
It would be a shame, Dirk Jr. Wait, actually, no, not Dirk Jr. She's eating my mom!
I need a fine.
Good job!
Where's the better...
Where's the better dragoon?
It would be a shame if something happened to you.
It would be a shame if someone wouldn't find back home.
Dragoon, you're doing great!
Oh no, where did better dragoon go?
Where did better dragoon go?
It would be such a shame if something happened to you.
What should we do with that child?
Oh look at them Ypeeeing.
Are they so cute?
They are so cute!
Look at them!
They are Ypeeeing.
Okay, let's see.
How full are they?
Contipation is tired!
He is Ypeeeing.
Let him sleep!
He wants to Ypeee!
See, he is Ypeeing.
Go Ypeee!
He has 8% sleep right now.
See, he's sleeping now.
Okay, let's see.
Oh my god, this is gonna take forever!
Why aren't you not adults yet?
What the heck?
Why aren't you adults within like 10 minutes?
What the fuck?
Grow!
Just grow!
Just grow, man.
Grow!
Oh, we gotta sleep too.
Guys, it's sleeping time.
Meep time!
Guys, other...
Oh, they're walking away.
Guys, if we all meep, they won't walk far.
What makes you say that?
If we meep and we wake up, they're just...
They're just gone.
...nowhere to be found.
Gone.
It's okay, less mouths to feed if you think about it.
It's called survival of the fittest, okay?
It's survival of the fittest for a reason, man.
Exactly.
Gets fucking eagled.
Who's not meeping?
The sky's not moving.
Who is not meeping right now?
The sky isn't moving.
Help, I need more sky.
We need...
The sky has to move.
Who is not eeping?
Who did not press Z and only pressed R?
Who is it?
Guys?
Guys, I'm gonna look at your eyes right now.
Oh my god!
Are your eyes closed?
That rabbit's so fucking fast.
Where...
Where's sky?
Why is it still nighttime?
Oh, there it is.
What the...
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
What is that?
What happened?
What is...
What's going on?
Wait, wait...
Oh!
That eagle.
Stealing?
Eagle?
Caca!
Did we have dreams?
Your pups are growing bigger!
Y'all!
More independent!
The center den while you are away.
As long as you pack affinities high.
Oh, fleas?
What is this?
Get out!
Get them away!
Where's the flea control?
Flea control, hello!
Where's flea control?
How do we stop this?
It's okay.
How do we stop fleas?
Just like...
I don't know.
How do we stop fleas?
Can I just, like, roll around in the dirt and like, stop the fleas?
What's the collar's for if we can't stop the fleas?
Don't worry.
I got food for you guys.
Alright guys, breakfast time!
Breakfast time!
Here you go!
It's breaky time!
Alright Dragoon.
It's time to make sure you're socialized for the world.
I need you to be well adjusted wolves.
Nice, alright.
Look at us go.
I'm so proud of our babies.
I don't wanna take breaks from- What?
Pissed on the pup?
Nuh uh.
I don't think so.
Why are you not 15 pounds yet?
Stop pissing on the puppies!
Stop!
That's my puppy!
Who's constipation?
Where is he?
Okay, right.
I'll do it on your food too!
No!
The food!
That's right!
He's eating the food.
Eating the pee pee food.
That's right.
That's what you- No!
Why did you do it yourself?
Fuck!
That's on you!
Oh my god!
That's right.
You gotta be extra socialized.
I want accidents!
The constipation is past the limit.
Fuck out!
How does he not sleep?
Okay, let's see.
Oh they're 10 pounds now!
Oh my god!
They're 10 pounds!
We just need 5 more pounds!
We need to hunt!
They're so close!
Alright, we call this when they're 15 pounds.
And then we call it.
Yeah, yeah.
So they're more independent so we don't have to come back so they can fend for themselves.
So they can fuck off.
Yeah, yeah.
We kick them out.
You're like- You're 18 now so you can- You're 18 now so you can- Freeloaders?
There's a plane in the sky!
Oh my god!
There's a flying thing!
It's yellow like you!
Like me!
Take it down, so we can take it down.
There can only be one!
There can only be one yellow.
What the heck?
Who allowed them to be yellow?
We gotta make sure they're 15 pounds or they'll have to pay rent.
Oh my god!
I got bison!
Yeah, you're still living at home.
Bison!
Yeah, there's bison near me!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm so far away.
Oh, I'm- Oh, okay.
Bison too scary.
I can't.
Bison's too strong.
We will get the bison.
We're getting invaded!
We are?
Cougars!
Oh, cougars!
Oh, I'm limping!
Okay, bison is- I have a fractured leg right now, so...
Unlucky.
I think I'm gonna be reduced to child care.
I can't hunt anymore.
Stay at home, father.
I'm gonna be a stay at home father.
I realize hunting- I- Just hunting wasn't for me.
Oh my god, where's the cougars?
No, they're in the den!
Okay, we have to find a new house for them too.
Because like, they're now- They're just gonna be filled with fleas now.
Oh!
No!
We have a couple- We have other dens though, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have to move to a new den.
Go places.
Okay, after we kill this cougar.
Where the fuck is the cougar?
Where is the cougar?
Where is it?
Oh, he's right here!
He's right here!
I'm helping!
I'm supervising!
I have a broken leg!
Yeah, yeah, doing- Yeah, you guys are doing great!
Good job!
Good job, guys!
Okay, okay.
Make sure to grab the neck, you know?
Grab the neck and tie it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's all in the neck.
There we go.
Neck tie him.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Now bring him down.
Now if you do a flip, you're gonna flip him to the back.
Okay, guys?
Flip it on his back.
Do it, do it.
Dude, he's tanky!
What the heck?
Bro, he's so tanky!
It's a cat!
That's- Menci, what are you doing?
You're not supervisor!
You're not supervising.
What the heck?
Yeah, what are you doing?
That's right.
Now go- Now bite the leg here, on the- the hind leg.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One hind leg, one neck.
Oh, oh, there you go!
Good job, guys.
Boom!
Good job.
That's what I call a team.
Kingy peed on the cougar.
Real quick.
Just mark our territory.
I know.
I have to know.
I'm gonna move the pups to a new den.
Cause there's too many fleas.
Let's go.
Too many fleas.
Okay, puppies.
41% fleas!
What the heck?
Okay, yeah, we're moving these puppies.
We are moving these puppies.
Yeah, these puppies need to get out.
Wait, where is my house?
Okay, where do we move?
To the middle, I guess.
The center of our territory.
Alright, uh, let's see.
Pack info.
Move to a- Do you want to move?
Yes.
Okay, you're off to a new den.
Continue.
Go hunting between...
Find a patch of tall grass.
Okay, we each pick up our child.
Pick up our child.
I've got my child.
Don't pee on my child!
Alright.
Okay, we're gonna go downwards, guys.
Actually, no, up.
Up is faster.
We're gonna go up here.
Follow me.
Follow your alpha.
Following the leader?
Where am I?
Give me a sec.
I need to figure out where I am first.
So this is west?
Which one's me?
Is this me?
Am I the red?
Yeah.
Don't worry, guys.
Follow the alpha.
I just got this!
I got this!
Yes, okay, we go straight.
We go straight.
She got a plan!
Pick up your child and go straight.
I hope we're not missing a child.
That's all I hope for.
Can you imagine?
We like forgot one.
All these bear attacks, cougar raids, and we just forget it at the mall.
Yeah, we forgot one kid at the mall.
We got everybody, right?
Is everybody here?
If the yellow wolf could pick up that child, Dragoon, yes.
Dragoon at reception.
Guys, I'm limping.
Give me a sec.
I can't run anymore.
I have to walk now.
Just walk for half.
Give me a sec.
Let me put down... Wait, where did my child go?
Oh my god.
He's digging!
Why are you digging?
Digging for treasure.
Dragoon, it's not time for fun right now.
You're filled with fleas.
You can't go to school.
You're nasty.
You got fleas.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Follow the alpha.
So close.
It's up close.
It's like, Jason!
Jason!
Oh my god, I don't have more stamina.
Oh my god, you have to drop your child.
Drop the baby.
No, concentration!
Stop!
Come here!
Drop the baby!
No, concentration!
Stop it!
Oh, damn.
Where's the Turner?
He's a fleeting one.
Is this the Turner?
Oh, there it is.
This is... okay.
This is a pretty shitty den, but...
It's fine.
Oh, we got food right here!
We can just put them here.
And we can hunt.
Alright, here we go.
Welcome, my new...
Alright, what do we call this house?
I'll take 50% of your name.
50%?
I'm starting to believe you just don't appreciate my naming capabilities.
I gave you 50%!
50%?
You take 50%?
It's just fair!
Okay, okay.
Moist.
Okay, 50% of that is...
No, no, no!
Is that how it works?
You give me a name and I take 50% of it!
That's exactly how it works!
Moist, moist cabbage den.
Okay, cabbage...
No!
Moldy foot fungus!
It's too late!
Dammit!
I already need your new home, guys.
Yippee!
What's our new home called?
Yay!
Alright, I'm gonna go find food.
Cabbage goon!
I'm gonna grab us some food.
Alright.
I just hunted something down.
Alright, I'm gonna eat this real quick.
It's so fast.
It's a small little antelope.
Hey, hey, hey.
Nice.
Holy shit, this guy is zooming!
Okay, I'm gonna eat this rabbit.
Nice.
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Vom, vom, vom, vom.
Alright, how much do they weigh now?
They are 10.5.
Okay, 11.
Someone wanted us at 11 pounds right now.
One is malnourished.
Who the fuck is not taking care of their children?
Who is it?
Why?
Who the heck is malnourished?
Dizzy!
Your child is malnourished!
Feed your child!
Feed!
Feed the baby!
I can't believe it.
Don't make us call Wolf Support on you.
I'm coming to Vom!
I'm trying to find more food for us.
I'm looking...
Holy shit, it's so hard to find food.
Camp, who chose this?
Who chose this?
There's no food around us.
Yeah, what the heck?
Dizzy, was it you?
I bet it was Dizzy.
Dizzy, why did you choose this place?
There's barely any food anywhere.
Tada!
Here's some food.
I got some hair.
And then we can Vom.
So hunting with bruised jaw and a broken leg.
Look, look.
This is...
Parenthood is hard.
It's difficult.
You think you can hunt an elk on your own?
That's fucking right.
Ow!
No constipation!
Stop sleeping!
You have to eat.
He's hungry!
I mean, he's sleepy.
Look at his... He has 7% sleep!
What do you mean?
Why is he never sleeping?
What do you mean he's actually sleepy?
What do you mean don't fucking sleep?
You're fucking...
Your fucking child is actually sleep deprived.
Why is he always sleepy?
He's playing too much video games.
I can't believe it.
I told you!
I told you making him play video games is a bad idea!
But someone has to farm gold!
If they can't be gold farmers...
And do your in-game chores...
Oh my god!
There's so many wolves on me!
Guys!
She's dead.
I'm fucking...
I'm dead!
Someone help me!
I got ambushed!
Wait, how far?
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
What the heck?
Someone help me!
Ow!
Leave me alone!
I got jumped!
I'm so dead!
What the heck?
I got jumped!
No!
Take a distractor!
Distract him!
I'm gonna live!
No!
Please stop me!
That's okay!
I'm running away!
It's okay!
I'm dead again!
No!
I'm so dead!
There's too many of them!
There's too many!
Help!
No!
I got distracted!
Distract him!
Leave me alone!
Oh god!
I got jumped!
I went to the wrong part of town!
Leave me alone!
Holy shit!
I'm running!
Oh my god!
I went... I accidentally invaded somebody else's territory!
I learned my lesson!
I'm sorry!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I'm so fucked up right now!
Dude, I'm almost dead!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
My leg!
Where's my...
Where's the children?
I need to sleep!
I need... I'm EP!
I need an EP!
EP time!
Goodnight everybody!
Wait, but the children!
Are they inside?
Oh okay, they're all inside.
Me me me me me me me me!
You're telling me to lose Blubber to run faster?
No!
The Blubber is what saved me!
I had cushioning!
The extra armor fat!
Yeah!
Me me me me me me me me me me!
Why is there fire in the forest?
What the heck?
Guys, don't go to the purple area!
It's dangerous!
Do not the purple!
The purple area!
Never go to purple!
Alright, how much do they weigh now?
12.3 Oh there's 13!
We need 2 more pounds!
Guys!
Easy!
I killed something!
Oh, it's spoiled probably.
I'm gonna go hunt again.
Hunting die!
It's time to hunt.
I need to make sure I don't go to purple.
But my leg is broken!
I don't think I can hunt anything.
Look, I hunted with a broken jaw!
If I can...
If I can do it, so can you!
Yeah!
Don't be a fucking coward!
Don't be a baby!
Don't be a baby, baby!
Our children need food!
You want them to starve after everything we've been through?
I would never.
What?
Oh, I can kill like baby deer!
Oh!
Oh, killing babies!
Yeah!
Look, it's all about killing the babies so that our babies can survive.
I found one!
Okay.
The rabbit is fast.
Nice.
I'm still like so hungry.
That's right, that's right.
Oh, oh that is fun!
It's just a baby!
That is so fun!
Nice!
That's what we like!
I got this!
You got this!
I believe in you!
Okay.
That is a elk.
Woo!
Okay.
Don't worry, I might bruise my mouth again.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, never mind!
The elk won!
Oh, god!
I'm not that strong!
I'm just...
I'm so weak!
It's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
We don't need that.
Oh, there's a car... the moose?
A deer...
Territorial marking...
Done!
Are you feeding the children?
Yeah, I'm going back now.
I'm gonna warm some.
I'm just gonna eat.
I'll just go with the little ones.
Oh wait, that's a fox.
I don't care about the fox.
I can't eat the fox.
Hunt in a pack?
No!
Those are for suckers!
We get four kills!
What the heck?
Yeah!
Why get one kill?
We can get four kills!
Exactly!
Yeah!
We don't give a fuck about...
teamwork.
Come on, children!
It's warm time!
Who needs teamwork?
This is individualism country!
Welcome to America!
We are free to do our own hunting!
We're all special individually!
We're all special individuals!
We're not here to think of it as a team!
That is for pussies!
Yeah, what the heck?
Yeah, what the fuck?
Teamwork?
Disgusting.
Yeah, so fucking disgusting.
This is solo queue.
This is the solo queue experience.
Wait, there's a...
Me, children, I made many warm piles.
A pack can take down larger prey.
More food for all.
If a wolf cannot take a larger prey, then they... if a single wolf can't do it, then they're worthless to the pack.
They don't belong into the pack!
Yeah, they don't belong!
Banish them!
Okay.
They should each individually be able to take down a giant animal.
Then starve!
If you don't do it, you starve.
Like I said, he's the Canadian and the German.
We're American at heart!
You won't understand!
You don't understand!
We're American at heart!
Let us be!
You just don't understand.
It's supposed to be the country of freedom.
I'm free to identify as American.
Yeah, exactly.
Fucking...
Preach it, sister.
Preach.
Oh wait, that's a fox.
I don't care about fox.
What are you... Oh my god, I can kill a bear!
Baby bear!
Oh god!
There's baby bear, but there's a mama bear!
I wanna eat the bear though.
Just kill the baby real quick and then run away from mama bear.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Can I please eat this?
Okay, nice.
I could eat the deer carcass.
Killed!
It's okay, I found the food.
Don't worry, I got more food for the children!
Yippee!
Yay!
I'm gonna finish this food!
Okay, I'm coming back.
Do not worry, dragon!
I know you haven't seen me in 20 years, but don't worry, I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
I'm coming back with more food.
Papa's coming back, child.
Please don't forget my face!
Am I running too far off?
Wait, is this the end of the game?
Is this too far from home?
Wait, where are you?
At home.
Okay.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to feed them.
Oh, I'm gonna eat this food real fast.
How can I feed them this?
Yum yum yum yum yum yum.
Yum yum yum yum yum yum yum.
How do I feed?
How do I fucking feed?
No, I don't wanna... I don't give a fuck about constipation.
First...
It's a bird!
It's a very serious topic, okay?
Wait!
Oh my god!
We're getting invaded!
Invaded?
I'll be in the cave!
You guys go!
I see him!
Put up!
Constipation!
Go in!
Die!
Are you fighting them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this.
Easy!
Oh my god, good job.
I'm gonna supervise.
Good job, guys.
You're doing great.
Don't let him run.
No!
Yeah!
Nice, alright.
See?
Perfect.
No witnesses.
I'm so proud of us.
Woooo!
I have a full belly!
I wanna feed you!
Oh, there we go.
Okay, I fed.
Wait, where's Dragoon?
Dragoon, why are you over there?
Who the fuck put you there?
Get over here.
Dragoon!
Yes, go home.
Yes, go inside.
Go eat.
E.P.
time.
You have lots of growing to do.
E.P.
time.
Dragoon, what are you doing?
Invited!
Yes!
Okay.
Go eat.
E.P.
time.
Eat.
See, they have full stomachs.
Yes!
Oh my goodness, they're almost done.
What are you doing with my child?
Come on!
Where's your child?
What are you doing?
My child, let him down!
Let go of my child!
Or I swear, better Dragoon's gonna get it.
Can't grow, he can't eat.
If you don't let go of my child, better Dragoon's gonna get it right now.
Better Dragoon's gonna get it so hard.
Say goodbye to your child.
Alright, eat.
Are you guys 15 pounds?
Good thing we have food at home.
They're 13 pounds.
You're so close!
We need two more pounds!
Come on, eat!
Eat, don't poop and you will get those pounds quickly!
Hurry up!
We need you to eat!
We've been at this for three hours!
Why are you still so small?
How dare you don't grow to an adult within three hours?
What the fuck?
Yeah, what the fuck is wrong with- Poor Dragoon!
Eat,
Dragoon, eat!
Yeah, it's constipation!
Good boy!
Okay, I have to eat!
It's EP time too.
Wait, I have to do...
One more playtime.
Guys, it's EP time.
EP!
EP time!
I lost Dragoon.
I hope he's okay.
Where's Dragoon?
No one knows!
I don't like this.
Dragoon is like walking further and further away.
It's like, goodbye mother.
Thank you for nourishing me.
I was very concerned.
Oh hey, look!
The loading screen!
Yippee!
I don't have one this time.
Oh, I have it.
My Dragoon is becoming too independent.
I don't like it.
No!
He's running off!
You're not supposed to-!
My Dragoon has become ill!
Why are you sick?!
Sick puppy!
Why?!
Who made you sick?!
There's an eagle!
Oh shit!
Wait, wait, wait!
Go inside!
Wait, wait, boys.
Go home!
Go into the den!
Go!
Go in!
Oh my god!
He's okay!
Please!
No!
Please go inside!
Please!
The eagle is coming down!
No!
He's looking!
He's looking at the children!
Oh, he's flying away!
He's flying away!
I picked up constipation.
Is that enough?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're...
It's fine!
Oh fuck.
They're flying around!
I'm so scared!
I don't wanna put it down!
I'm scared!
Come away!
Stupid bird!
I'm gonna eat my food.
Oh, it gave up!
It gave up!
See, even though my dragoon is sick right now, at least he's not stupid.
He's not stupid!
He knew!
He knew when to hide!
Good job, dragoon!
You might be sick right now, but at least you know when to go inside.
That's my child!
I'm gonna get my food to vomit.
The constipation just ran away!
Like, what?
You just panicked and sprinted!
Like, what was that for?
Aqua!
Dizzy, your fucking puppy is so malnourished!
Everybody else is 4 to almost 15 pounds!
Yours is still 15!
Feed your fucking...
Feed your child!
Go away from my food!
My food.
Leave it!
Good dragoon.
You're socialized.
You're socialized enough that you know when to hide in the cave when there's an eagle.
Unlike some children.
I wonder whose child just sprinted away.
Food, food, food, food, food, food, food, food!
Oh my goodness.
Look.
He's just... his immune system isn't as good as the others!
It's not his fault!
It's just poor genetics, okay?
Poor genetics?
I just passed on somebody should use genetics.
What can I say about that?
It's his mom's fault.
I'm a strong genetic wolf.
It's not my fault.
I blame the mother.
I blame whoever is the mother.
My genes...
gave him the best possible...
genes.
He's tired!
Let's go!
Nom nom nom nom nom nom!
Oh, I need to eat too.
Om nom nom nom nom nom nom nom!
Alright.
Come on, come on!
I have to chase this food for so long!
Nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom!
Alright, let's see.
Mine needs 0.5 more pounds.
And then he's... better dragoon!
Better dragoon needs to stop eating!
He's gonna get too plump!
Too plump!
Maybe our children got switched.
And like, but a dragoon is actually my child, cause I'm a plump little boy.
Ha ha ha ha!
You gotta stop overfeeding your kid!
Dokililly lovechild!
You gotta stop overfeeding him!
Ha ha ha ha!
Let the other pups grow!
Yeah, you're denying our growth.
Yeah, exactly.
This is why my dragoon is ill!
Bro, this is why your puppy's a beast.
This is why.
You need a fucking...
Stop shaming the puppy!
Bro, he's like, two pounds heavier than all the other puppies!
It's not the average weight of a puppy!
Jesus!
Bro, we need to put that puppy on a treadmill!
A treadmill?
Bro!
That puppy needs to be healthy!
It's a baby fat!
Ha ha ha ha!
He's just fluffy!
It's just a baby fat talking about.
Dragoon, why are you...
Please socialize with the other puppies!
What are you doing?
Why are you away from them?
Socialize!
I shall follow the footsteps of Sasuke.
Dragoon, please.
I trained you better to be social.
Why are you a loner?
I don't understand.
Mother, you wouldn't get me.
You don't understand, mother.
You're just like the other parents.
Dragoon, stop walking away!
Play with these children!
You all grew up together!
There's two of them.
You're turning into a gamer!
Ha ha ha ha!
No!
Social distancing because of sickness?
I didn't want you to become like me, Dragoon!
I tried everything I could to raise you right!
Ha ha ha ha!
And for what?
I like how...
I love how he's also like...
He's like emo as fuck.
Because he's like the only puppy that's like a black puppy.
So he's super emo right now.
Ha ha ha ha!
Mom, don't talk to me!
It's not a phase, mom!
Oh my god, mom!
You're embarrassing me!
Oh my god!
Time to leave soon!
Almost all your pups have grown 15 pounds.
Very soon it will be time to leave the den and travel to your summertime home base.
Called a rendezvous site.
Start planning your trip by opening a world map which now shows.
Then feed your pups to get the smallest one over 15 pounds.
Yeah, that's really far.
Ha ha ha ha!
That is some...
That is...
Quite a distance.
That's pretty far.
Wait, no, there's one really close by!
Yeah, yeah, we can take them there, right?
Yeah, easily!
That's not that far.
Yeah, yeah, we'll call it when we get to the rendezvous.
Ha ha ha!
We'll call it when we get to the rendezvous site.
It's not that far.
Just do a little wham and then, like, what's the goal?
Dragelon, please!
Please, their friends are over here!
Please, Dragelon, stop!
Bro, my puppy doesn't even look like a fucking puppy.
He looks like a cat.
He actually looks...
He looks like a fucking cat.
Please.
Please, don't socialize.
He got my tail!
Alright,
who is still...
Mine's almost 15 pounds.
He just needs two more.
Okay, Dragelon, here.
I have food for you.
Oh, he's behind me!
Oh, he's eeppy.
Stop playing with the stick!
Stick!
There's other things to play!
It's like the stick is like the video game.
Mom, I don't wanna play with the other paws.
I wanna play with my stick.
God, Mom, I can't just pause stick playing.
You don't understand.
You don't understand, Mom.
Oh my God, it's an animal!
Oh, dragon!
Oh, blaggy!
No!
Dragon, please!
Stop playing with the stick!
Dragon!
That's right, that's right!
Dragon, no, no, no!
Don't mess with me!
Go, go, go, go!
Go!
Play with the other kids!
Okay, I'm gonna help.
That's right, that's right, that's right!
That's right!
Get over here!
Get out!
Get outta here!
Nice.
Wait, they're junior high school... Okay, that's not my child.
No, wait!
Oh, never mind.
I don't care.
Yeah, yeah, that's not mine.
That's not my kid.
Oh, who cares?
Yeah, that, that... Oh, thank God.
As long as it's not Dragoon, it's fine.
Come on.
Eat a little bit.
You just need two more pounds and you'll be fine.
You'll be big and strong and be alpha just like me.
Come on!
You need four more pounds!
Just stop sleeping!
Eat!
Okay, Aqua needs to keep eating.
Aqua has a full pound?
Dizzy!
Your child is a runt!
We should have let that child... Damn!
Your child is anorexic.
What the heck?
Bro!
What happened?
Feed your child!
Don't let better Dragoon take all the food!
Wake that child up!
Oh my God, I'm constipated.
Please wake up!
Wake him up!
You have to eat!
Dizzy, wake your child up and make her eat!
She doesn't need to sleep.
She needs to put weight in that body.
Don't constipation has so much sleep.
Just wake up!
It's like 60% sleep.
Bro, what the fuck?
Girl, you have one pound left!
Don't wake the child.
It's time to be...
Come on!
Here, eat!
I'm gonna wake your child.
Oh my God, your child is so fucking sleepy.
Yeah, he's like passed out, dude.
Bro, I'm sleeping now.
It's sleeping time.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Sorry,
am I snoring?
So it's like when VTubers are not the best parents?
Who would have thought it?
Dragoon's healthy again!
Oh, he's eating!
They're eating!
Your pups have grown to 15 pounds!
Yes!
Yay!
Journey to summer home!
They no longer need the dens.
Now it's time to journey.
Take them to your home base for the summer.
You need a spot with sun and shades.
Alright, pick them up.
It's time!
Mewtwo must select a new site on the map, then lead them.
Find a patch of wolf to tell your pups to hide.
They will be safe while they're away.
Okay, I'm just gonna pick them up.
Fuck this.
Yeah, fuck it.
Just pick them up.
Where's the rendezvous spot?
Is that the grass?
I think so.
Right?
That is, right?
Yeah, that's the grass.
Okay, I'm gonna go... Yeah, there's one that's super close.
Yeah.
Alright.
Get over here.
Get over here!
I'm gonna pick you up!
Dragon!
And he's like, Mom!
Those are picking me up!
This is for kids!
Mom, don't pick me up!
Don't pick me up!
This is embarrassing!
Mom!
I'm grown up now!
I'm two months old now, Mom!
Mom!
You're embarrassing me, Mom!
Not in front of my friends, Mom!
Not in front of my friends!
Oh, God!
Mom!
You wouldn't get it!
You don't understand, Mom!
God!
Constipation doesn't let his mom pick him up all the time!
Why can't you be cool like his mom?
God!
Just leave me alone, Mom!
I wish I literally was my mom!
No, you're getting nuts!
No, you did not say that, Dragoon!
You did not!
You would have been named Constipation!
Is that what you wanted?
If she was your mom!
You want Constipation!
That would have been your name if it wasn't for me!
Ha ha ha ha!
It's not that bad, Mom!
No one brought us Constipation!
Yeah!
God!
It's not even...
Mom, it's pronounced...
Constipation!
Yes, it's pronounced Constipation!
It's Latin!
For peace!
God!
You're so insensitive, Mom!
Mom, please!
It's 2024!
Grow up!
Wait, then Dragoon got lost?
Wait, what?
They lost their child for like five seconds!
Ha ha ha ha!
Well, I had a break.
Fuck!
Wait!
Get your child!
How did you lose your kid?
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh my God!
Alright, I'm gonna hold it until like...
they get better Dragoon.
Over here.
Go get your child!
Come on!
Mom, no!
I'm running away!
I like how someone's like...
Mom, it's 2024!
Constipation is a common name!
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay, okay...
Get up the times, Mom!
Okay, here.
This is my Moranebu site.
It means peace in Latin.
Summertime hard!
Let's go!
Ha ha ha ha!
Yippee!
You can loaf around.
I think this is a good time to call it.
Yeah, I think I've been constipated for long enough.
Ha ha ha ha!
That was fun!
Great time!
This was so good!
I'm so glad we all opened to ceremony, but I've still been looking for a den.
Yeah, we've so been looking for holes!
We've still been looking and pissing.
Yeah, we feel like, what are we doing?
Alright, one last howl, yes!
As a group, come over here!
Let's go!
We howl together!
Awww!
Child
was unmalnourished!
Malnourished!
Wooo!
No food!
Hahaha!
Wooo!
Thanks for joining me, literally!
I'm glad we picked this game!
Hahaha!
I'm glad we picked this game to play together.
And when you suggested this game, I was like, this is the one!
Yeah, this is it!
We need this game!
I need this fucking game!
Hahaha!
Thank you to the Shrimp Goons for teaching us how to play!
We really appreciate it!
Thank you so much Shrimp Gooning Inc!
Thank you Shrimp Goons Incorporated for teaching us!
We were able to get this far because of all you!
Hahaha!
Our puppies would have died like four minutes We wouldn't even have puppies!
What a loss!
Hahaha!
We've still been so fucking lost!
Look, that is why we are supervisors, not workers!
We're very good at supervising!
We're very bad at doing anything else!
We make good decisions!
Yes, we are the decision people!
Hahaha!
This game is so good!
Thank you 500 Hour Andes!
Thank you!
For finding us a den!
And taking care of our children!
And feeding them!
And fighting off the predators!
We really appreciate it!
Hahaha!
Thank you Lily for joining me!
Thank you for having me!
It was so good!
It was fun!
Until next time!
Until next wolf quest anniversary edition!
Hahaha!
Thank you Shrimps!
I hope you had fun!
All it dragons!
Goodbye dragons!
Bye dookie!
I'm going to talk to my channel!
Bye bye!
Hahaha!
I'm going to close the server!
Goodbye!
You will never reunite with your children ever again!
Oh shit!
I almost forgot to save!
Hahaha!
Oh!
Hard work gone!
No way!
Okay I saved!
Okay!
Alright I'll see you later Lily!
I'll see you!
Bye bye!
Oh my god that was so fun!
We just had a fun time!
With Lily and I!
We went in blind!
We were so confused!
So I'm glad we ended up opening the server to the people who actually have experience with this game!
To teach us how to raise the children!
I hope you guys had a really fun time watching!
It was a really fun time collabing with Lily!
Let me swap real fast!
Boop boop boop boop boop!
Oh my god!
I think like the exciting thing about it is just like meeting lots of new people!
And like collabing with so many new people!
But yeah!
I had an amazing time with Lily today!
And just messing about!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Oh!
If you're not...
For those who aren't...
For those who didn't see the new community post for members!
For the member goon!
I'm currently working with a Minecraft team right now!
On making a new community post!
A community server!
A Dragoon community Minecraft server!
So...
I'm really happy because like...
Gumi was the one that hit me up with...
Not hit me up!
Sorry!
I asked Gumi because she's really...
She's in like all these like SMPs and stuff!
Like Minecraft SMPs!
Like the... which one was it?
The really big one?
Which one was it that has like Spanish integration?
She's in like those SMPs!
And she actually was in a Dream SMP as well!
And she did like the MCC as well!
And has won the MCC!
So she has like so many connections with...
With like the...
Minecraft...
Minecraft people!
And she...
Yeah the QSMP!
Gumi is actually in the QSMP!
So I asked her for like...
If she knows somebody who can make the...
Dragoon members...
Minecraft server for us!
So she connected me with...
With this team!
That...
With this team that has done like...
Minecraft servers!
And Minecraft maps for like...
A lot of like Minecraft content creators!
As well as...
Like a lot of like SMPs and stuff...
For content creators!
For Minecraft people!
As well as they were the ones that made...
The Twitch Rivals!
Minecraft maps and Minecraft servers!
For Twitch Rivals!
So like she connected me up with them!
And they are currently working on the...
Server at the moment for member goons!
This Minecraft server will only be...
For the current Dragoon members!
So it will be like synced up to the members list!
Um... but...
And like I made a post asking...
For...
For like what your input is and what you are looking for...
In the server so if there is any plugins you want...
Like what the lobby map will look like...
So like we are hoping to have like a place...
Where when you log in you will be dropped into the...
Lobby area!
So we need to give them like features...
Of what they want!
So if you are a member goon...
Please check out the member community post...
To give your input on what you want...
For the Minecraft server!
Um...
Also tomorrow!
Is the charity stream...
Slash auction!
Um... I am really excited about the auction...
Um... I am really thankful for...
The help of...
Little man?
Yes...
Little man...
Um... they have been helping me a lot with setting all the auction stuff...
They have actually helped me with like...
Getting in touch with like Tiltify...
And like the brain and behavior foundation...
Research foundation...
Um... they have been working really hard...
Setting everything up for us...
And listing up all the auction items...
I am super duper excited...
I will give you guys... those who are in the member stream...
I can give you guys a sneak peek...
Of like some of the items...
Uh... let me see if I can find...
Um... I will give you a sneak peek...
Of some of the items... so for example...
This!
Will be in the auction...
One of them because the other one is for me...
But here are some of the items...
That will be in...
The auction...
So like a... two of a kind...
The other one is for me...
So technically two of a kind...
Um... Doki plush...
Um... and...
They are currently setting it up at the moment...
So like some stuff to look forward to...
The stream itself...
It's going to be very random...
There will be like some stretch goals and everything...
Um... and...
Um... I am still trying to figure out...
What to do on the stream...
But the auction might start...
Tonight... or... before...
The stream starts...
And... um... LittleMad told me to let you guys know...
That if you are looking to bid on the item...
You need to have a...
Tiltify account...
And you have to link your...
Link a payment...
Method and your address on your account...
Your account has to be registered on Tiltify...
And also...
Have a...
Have payment method linked...
As well as your address registered...
So you'll be able to... um...
Bid on the items...
Uh... so like...
I just need you guys to remind you guys about it...
How long will the charity stream be?
Um... I will try my best to stream as long as I can...
I won't... I don't want to force myself too hard...
To stream a very long time...
But the auction itself...
Would be around... would be...
Uh... will last all the way...
For 24 hours...
That is my hope...
Um... so if we do...
Or 2 days... I want the auction to be around 2 days...
Uh... so people have...
As much time to bid it and everything...
So I'm gonna try and have the auction itself...
Be 2 days...
Um... there is around 30 items...
In the auction...
And I'm super duper excited...
Uh... I'm super duper excited...
For the auction and hope that...
Um... a lot of you guys enjoy some of the items...
That's on there...
Um... but yeah!
I hope you guys had a great time...
Um...
With the collab with Lily...
And uh... enjoyed just like...
Um... me meeting...
Lots of new people...
Um... next week I will be...
I know I have one collab that's finalized...
Well... we haven't decided the game yet...
We haven't decided the game yet...
But... um... I reached out to...
ChibiDoki if they wanted to collab with me...
Cause I thought it would be funny...
Cause we're both Dokis...
Uh... so next week... I'm still deciding the game...
So I'll be collabing with...
Uh... collabing with ChibiDoki next week...
Um... other than that...
Uh... there is so much work...
So... so much work...
I'm always so busy...
Yesterday I spent all my day just working...
I'm always super nervous...
Uh... regarding collab...
I know like... I always reach out to people for collab...
But also...
I'm always super nervous when collabing...
Because... um... I...
You know... when it's like new people...
I don't know what the chemistry is like...
So like... um... I try to pick games out...
That I feel would work the best...
Between us and everything...
And... uh...
Um... so...
It's always so nerve-wracking before a collab...
Because I don't know what the chemistry is gonna be like...
And everything... as like a one-to-one thing...
And... um...
And I'm just happy that...
Lily enjoyed herself...
And... uh... we all had a great time!
Also!
So my mod reminded me...
New merch!
Yes!
The...
Lunar... Yeah sorry... the Lunar New Year is over...
I know the Lunar New Year is over...
But...
We have Lunar New Year merch!
Look!
I'm still getting ahead of...
Planning merch in advance, okay?
It's very difficult...
So... the Lunar New Year merch...
Will be on sale...
On... March 3rd...
At 5pm PST...
There will be 200 limited edition bundles...
That come with a signed postcard...
And... only the red pocket envelopes...
The pre-order for all of this...
Will be up for a month...
And then everything but the red pocket envelopes...
Will be off the store...
So... red pocket envelopes...
Will be in the store forever...
But everything else will be off the store...
Because it's limited...
It's only there for pre-order...
So yeah!
So there's a pillow, acrylic stand...
Button, sticker, and red pocket envelopes...
Snapshots will be in the bundle only...
That's not limited...
But the limited ones will be the signed postcards...
So that is...
The Lunar New Year Merch!
I think those are all the updates...
Yes, I know I might be late...
Ivy, thank you for the super chat!
Lunar New Year may be over...
But Year of the Dragon is still for 10 more months...
Exactly!
We think like that, Ivy!
Thank you for the super chat!
No, the red pocket will be on the store forever...
Everything else will be gone...
After the pre-order is done...
But yeah!
I hope you guys had a great time!
Bye!
I have to work now...
After the stream...
I have to do the charity event work stuff...
But anyway, as always everybody...
Stay hydrated, posture check...
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing...
And if you suffer me...
Head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!